gentlemen were live yeah dude Stevo
ladies and gentlemen Brian we've been in
the house
Stevo preparing himself for his long
stretch in the pokey from mocking
SeaWorld openly on top of a very
dangerous sign dude there's a video of
you you were streaming live while you
you [ __ ] with the SeaWorld sign and
would you write two different ones I had
the highway sign where I changed to say
SeaWorld sucks and then there's the the
one where I climbed up to 150 foot tall
crane okay I think both of them made me
[ __ ] my pants one of them we were
watching it Brian and I were watching it
and my toes were curling I know you're
watching it live lifting up yeah we're
watching knows when we're in Sea Road
when you are I mean San Diego and you
were doing the sign one you're climbing
up the sign yeah dude yeah how did you
live fall that was like appropriate it
was right there down in San Diego near
SeaWorld the highway sign said SeaWorld
Drive and I changed it to say SeaWorld
sucks I guess it was appropriate my
crane one was completely [ __ ] idiotic
there is okay let me protest SeaWorld at
some random construction site no we're
[ __ ] near SeaWorld you know let me
[ __ ] bring an inflatable killer whale
like a toy whale climb up 150 foot crane
when you're a hundred and fifty feet up
in the air nobody no one's gonna be able
to see your [ __ ] toy whale you know
what's that dot right yeah Stephen a dot
I know you they know been there could
even tell it's right by the time I get
up there I got 80 firefighters 18 cops a
helicopter and a SWAT team I'm lying the
problem with that stuff is if something
real was going down and they had put all
the resources Oh trust me I get it yes
why I'm going to jail
how long you go to jail I have a 30-day
sentence but I don't think my god not
that I think they automatically cut it
in half and then maybe even get out
quicker how does that work I didn't
necessarily have to go to jail at all
like I asked my lawyer to get me in jail
time specifically because my [ __ ]
crane snot was so idiotic I was like man
I gotta go to jail that would be the
only one tiny little part of it that
makes any sense at all because like if
you're trying to make a statement about
captivity right right put yourself in
kept right you know I asked for it and
so you asked for jail look you couldn't
now to Jim I'm sure I could I could have
done like community service like you
know whatever like I was like now dude
because I'm a [ __ ] attention [ __ ] so
like I'm like dude like like scrubbing
graffiti does not a cool story like corn
of jail that's a headline
you know like I'm gonna get [ __ ] I'm
gonna go to jail
that's [ __ ] that's newsworthy it's so
ridiculous to the judge what not I never
even had to go to court because I you
know it like they oh they all worked it
out so when they kept postponing my
arraignment and when I went you know by
the time that like the prosecutor and my
lawyer finally worked out a deal then
when the arraignment was back on they
said hey we reached a deal and then they
closed it all down in the jail before
[Laughter]
his criminal record ever did was the
first time the first time I was like 16
or 17 like going to high school in
England and there's got nailed with some
weed you ever jail in another country oh
I've been in jail in like five countries
what's the scary five I've been to
Canada England America Sweden and I'm
not counting Mexico because that was
more of a catch and release
what would happen in Mexico ah it was
like I was you know like blacking out on
Special K you know like ketamine and I
was like climbing on this roof and like
I kind of like fell off of it and and I
don't know they just grabbed me and like
detained me wasn't like yeah but it was
pretty scary mirrors legit when you're
in when you're in Mexico like that
that's [ __ ] you can vanish yeah yeah
like a lot of people vanished right I
find that el chapo guy hmm they're not
gonna find a ferret no apparently they
were closing in on him and he fell and
broke his leg and he was carried off by
his guards yeah apparently later they're
closed
they keep closing in on right but that's
a good disappear for that guy he's
psyched to disappear most people
disappear in Mexico yeah people vanish
in Mexico like those students like the
43 students that were murdered
it's this scary [ __ ] right so when you
were in Mexico when you would you sober
up in jail did you like realize what had
happened no like I don't know I mean I
guess like it all just like kind of
worked out it wasn't it wasn't big deal
you know they they let me go
but they just kicked Joe yeah in Sweden
I was in like properly in jail for
[ __ ] five days I calm for
international drug smuggling did you
bring in well what I did I was
videotaping it and I was in Norway and I
put a bunch of weed into a condom I tied
it in a knot and swallowed it choked on
it I was like peeking up blood trying to
get it out like God so then I flew from
Norway to Sweden
so that it would you know you put it on
video oh yeah put it on the Internet
what yeah I mean later you know later
but I'm so happy so I swallowed it in
Norway and got in an airplane to Sweden
so that so that way I'm crossing
international lines you know to qualify
as an international drug smuggler
then when I got to Sweden you know I had
my M I was promoting my tour every
interview like there they say like oh
yeah how you know and listen mom man I
think I might die of intestinal
strangulation because I swallowed this
big package of drugs and it won't come
out you know cuz it took days I didn't
come out for like six and a half days
so this says so every like like a
reporter like rode through their article
or whatever it was and the cops are at
the newspaper and so then they like they
arrested me like after I [ __ ] it out and
and they took me to the jail and and you
know like they brought me into the from
the jail to the hospital put me in this
like cat scan machine which revealed
they said a foreign object in my body I
still don't know what what that was and
they kept me in a cell for five days
[ __ ] into plastic bags they [ __ ]
digging through my [ __ ] and then after
five days in there they brought me back
to the hospital for another leg scan and
it showed that like the foreign object
had only moved like three centimeters
like my body is so like they're like oh
[ __ ] it and they they just made me pay a
fine and go you don't even know what it
is I don't know I don't know they said
it was like a key and I don't know sharp
yeah might be still in ten years did you
ever get yourself looked at again not an
update that's my friend is he care that
much but Sweden I was wild man and again
I was super psyched because I knew I was
on that little scrolling [ __ ] thing
on CNN at the bottom site for that well
yeah I mean I thought I mean because we
came now that when they brought me to
the station initially like they put my
backpack on the table and I reached into
it like the first pocket they reached
into the first thing they pulled out was
a [ __ ] ecstasy pill like like with
the [ __ ] like they had and it had a
print like an imprint of a smiley face
on it it
Oh God and I didn't even remember it
being in there and like [ __ ] I didn't
know that was in there and then I
thought man maybe I'll be in Sweden for
a while but turns out the ecstasy wasn't
even like that you know they weren't
even that bent out of shape over ecstasy
they're more pissed about weed over
there really yeah I don't know why it's
just like a tree things
well because we'd like they think it
makes you lazy I think and they're not
cool that's how it is in Asia well I
think I think you know they're like you
know this that makes you lazy and and
and we're not [ __ ] lazy people and so
they they want a really appreciate that
really frustrates me that that
stereotype with weed making you lazy
that that drives me crazy that is the
one that drives me the most nuts you're
lazy you're lazy when we does not make
you [ __ ] lazy
it just doesn't I'm not lazy it drives
me nuts
I was never lazy man when I was loaded
no my longest time in jail well you know
like I got I was I was in LA County jail
for five days one time I got arrested
for felony obscenity and principle to
second-degree battery in Louisiana whoa
yeah because it was like I was doing my
own show what does that mean principal -
it means that I raged like an assault
like I was doing my old show and you
know that part of it was I was chugging
out of a tequila bottle like throughout
the whole thing and I'd like you know
whatever like yeah I had the tequila
bottle at the edge of the stage and you
know some kid like climbed on the stage
and grabbed the bottle and I see these
bouncers come over and just neutralize
it you know I don't like damn these guys
are good these [ __ ] bouncers are pro
so I said who wants to get on this stage
and try to run from one side of the
stage to the other past the bouncers you
know it's a British Bulldog will play a
British Bulldog and these guys are gonna
[ __ ] you up so there's like one kid is
like this bony little skinny little 19
year old kid was like jumping up and
down
pointing at himself he was just so he
wanted it so bad and I couldn't I had to
pick him so I picked this kid and he ran
he just ran I'm videoing it myself I
said one two three go the kid like runs
halfway across the stage and they just
grab and it was totally anticlimactic
and these three like football player the
college football player bouncers like
they just lifted him up like in unison
like over their heads and legs just
spiked the kid on his head on his own no
and he was like twitching and and like
you know I don't think they're the
police report said he was bleeding out
of an ear or something like and and and
it was really [ __ ] up you don't they
do that when they knew that he was gonna
run across me I don't know I never said
slam him on his head you know I'd said
that maybe [ __ ] but but yeah and so like
you know in my mind I'm thinking ah dude
this is such a lawsuit like this is this
is bad you know so that's you know honey
you're not thinking oh my god this poor
kids too but like whatever it was it was
just all bad you know it was all bad in
my head like the mantra the show must go
on
like pretend it's not bad and just
continue so I'm like I was like [ __ ] on
the video and somebody in the crowd was
was had a home video camera rolling on
and this was like what was it 2002 so
like I mean is is before they had
cameras on cell phones and someone's got
like a [ __ ] like VHS home video
camera and on the tape which they turned
over they were like that's a crime so it
turned it over to the cops
or they escaped the newspaper in the
newspaper gave it to the cops so on the
thing I'm like that kids being loaded
into an ambulance [ __ ] who wants to
play another round of British oh no did
anybody sign up for round time I can't
remember if we did or not but but the
assault though honestly well your day as
principal to second-degree battery sir
whatever I think that's how I think I
have it right
and like there you know like that was a
crime but but like the people like you
know that watch this video they really
were upset with with Stevo and so there
was another point in the video where I
state is an industrial staple gun to
staple my ballsack to my leg no normal
[ __ ] I'm covered in blood to like
because like part of the other part of
the show outbreak a light bulb over my
head and like pick up like a piece of
broken glass and like like literally
slash my cuz the time I bleed so much
and it heals really faster I just bleed
all over myself and smeared blood
everywhere and and so I'm covered in
blood and I've got my dick and boss just
blatantly out and I'm holding the
industrial staple gun getting ready to
staple my ballsack to my leg and I say
this is not art this is just to be
offensive and so like you know being
that it was Louisiana in one of these
parishes they deemed that felony
obscenity hmm which was a saving grace
man because like because the story on
that one it was like Stevo got arrested
for stapling his balls to his leg you
know like the thing with the kid didn't
really play that much damage I'll tell
you right now you had brain damage I
never so you get spiked on your head
some cells died I mean like I got
properly sued so did you go to did you
lose or did you go to court was dead
settled totally settled it you can see
how much he got 50 grand that's it's not
that good but you know did you talk to
the member did you talk to bouncers you
go why did you spike him on his head why
didn't just grab him like he just
grabbed him I know
grabbed him would have been funny you
know right just grab and take him out of
there help you know to hold him over
throw him into the audience like a stage
divers yeah yeah they really really it
was upsetting they should have done that
see the problem is you give people a
green light like that okay you've seen
some [ __ ] the bouncers have done to
people when people climb onto that stage
there's a green light I mean right it's
like it's sort of like the cop thing you
know like when when cops like did you
see that video recent video of the cop
grabbing the school girl she's in her
desk she won't get out of her desk
and he just [ __ ] ragdolls her and
slams her in the desk on the ground it's
when cops have the green light when they
can do whatever they want to do then
you're leaving it up to the discretion
of this guy that's probably not thinking
that straight right a little stressed
out yeah I got beat up by a few balance
there's one guy I grabbed me took me out
back and just like pushed me against the
wall just kept on slapping him in the
face me wouldn't let me go
he like sat there for like 10 I was like
18 and he's just like wailing on my face
then you'll be like you gonna do that to
get [ __ ] and then just like
punch me in like I was captured like
because I was outside of the club he was
just ramming against the wall and [ __ ]
like they're not supposed to do that
right we left that club in Louisiana
that night I knew I was gonna hear about
it again and I sure enough like it took
a couple weeks but you know I was like
sleeping off a cocaine bender and my
roommate says hey man you really got to
get up for this and there's like the LA
the LA fugitive division they had it
like they they had a fugitive warrant
out of Louisiana with for you yeah yeah
there's a there are two charges the
felony obscenity and then the second
second-degree battery thing
la you should just let that felony
obscenity but they should be like you
keep that yourself you [ __ ] but the
thing was that like
they they gave me a one hundred and
twenty thousand dollar bail like warrant
for for the the battery and then for the
felony obscenity they gave me a million
so I got this I showed up on the the
like the fugitive list like in like pole
position number one with
1.12 million dollar bail oh my god and
so their position and Ed's and so like
they they brought me in they're like
what you do and I'm like I stapled my
balls to my leg like that nobody could
understand it
and I was in LA County Jail in the
protective custody where I'll be
starting on December 9th they're gonna
put you in protective custody what yeah
I mean I got I got kind of high-profile
dude anything you you would be in
protective custody to you and you know
they I mean at the time it was 2003 I
just got my back tattoo but the movie
wasn't out yeah it's nobody knew about
it in the cops like we're pretty psyched
to have me in there and they brought me
in to like they're out there office
whatever like they're giving me like
boxes and boxes of cookies and taking
pictures of my bag tattoo I remember
there they were like ah dude you'll be
fine in here man what is the back tattoo
through taking a picture my self
portrait oh my god be fine in here man
this is Robert Downey jr. block you know
like we've had they're listing up all
the celebrities that have been in there
you got Tommy Lee like everybody they're
like and and ODB's always in here you're
actually in his self dude [ __ ] yeah this
has a good one the longest I was in jail
was ten days in Orlando for thousands of
thousands for drunk driving now that's
[ __ ] up
yeah yeah like that that was [ __ ] up
and I remember like that was in 1996 and
I mean I hadn't really broken out yet
you know so like I couldn't really my
before I mean I barely could afford to
get to Orlando like I lived in South
Florida like near West Palm Beach and so
I could I just scrape money together for
a for a Greyhound bus to get to Orlando
and I was like I can't afford I can
afford to get there once for my
arraignment I can't afford to like go
get Rand and then set a date and then
come back and then come back again and
my I had a public
the public defender had said yeah I saw
the video we're not gonna be able to do
much about this you know that was the
one where my arrest report said
defendant declined roadside sobriety
tests stating he would prefer to take a
nap that I wasn't actually drunk I was
just really tired and so inside told the
public defender guy was like man I can't
afford to like go home and come back
again so they got the arraignment can we
just like plead guilty and like ask that
I go to jail like right away actually
did the whole ten days so what is a
what's worse Mexico or Orlando as far as
jail well the the Mexico was just like
holding you know like Orlando was like
proper like proper jail like the like
process and it was pretty mellow because
like in Orlando they said like you know
as you get like you know process you'll
get prosecuted you get like orientation
you know the kind of breakdown what it's
going to be like they give you a tub of
like like a Tupperware tub of like your
belongings where you've got like
whatever like your blue a blanket like a
soap like you know they won't let you
have a razor but like a toothbrush and
they're like this year this is your
belongings okay like you're gonna have
it at the foot of your bed you're gonna
keep it like this and like [ __ ] don't
piss us off don't do anything wrong
because if you hear pack up your
belongings you know then what that means
is then you're gonna pack all your [ __ ]
into your tub and you're going into the
[ __ ] dungeon you know and what that
means like is that like it if you're in
a dungeon then down there they're like
and there's just not there's a you're
just not on camera down there like
anything can happen to you like and like
you know that was like sort of the
incentive to like be on your best
behavior you know because I hear like
everything's on camera like you can you
know it was just like they're just
letting you know that if you
[ __ ] up if you [ __ ] up you're going down
and bad shits gonna happen to you
because you're gonna be because only
people go down to the dungeon are like
like dangerous people you don't want to
be like [ __ ] with like they're gonna
be with you that's the yeah basically
like basically like the the worst people
who are more inclined to hurt you are in
the dungeon and Okemos yeah if I
remember cuz I remember like being it
like always on camera no matter what
happened I don't there was no cameras
but they're just like we're not gonna
like down there and nothing can
nothing's gonna be nothing nothing gets
stopped think you're gonna get fired
you're gonna be [ __ ] and then it
worked it kept like everything pretty
like civil you know like I I was I was
very well behaved
now when you're in jail for ten days is
it easy like in ten days can you get
drugs in 10 days or do you have to like
get to know the system I don't think
that you're gonna have as much luck in
County Jail like like County Jail by
definition means that you have a
sentence of less than one year and then
at the point of it being one here then
it's called prison and in prison I think
it's like that's where you can get
whatever you want and all that like
really yeah I don't think Ellie I don't
think like jail is is as you know
probably make hooch is probably the big
thing right I mean and maybe like I
don't have that much experience I don't
know but like I couldn't get yeah I was
doing like backflips for extra food and
[ __ ] like people give you food like the
people that work there I gather the
other inmates the people that work there
you know when they had the cart that
came by and and I remembered to like
there was like in Orlando the jail is a
big business in Orlando because it's
kind of like Mecca you know like maybe
even more than make it like more
families I travel from all over the
world to take the biggest tech tourist
thing so like the business is like they
say like you come to Orlando on vacation
you leave on probation and then return
on violation
and I'd say that all the theme parks
there right they have SeaWorld they're
closing SeaWorld down because you know
in California they just made it illegal
for them to breathe in captivity they
[ __ ] made they banned captive breeding
in the California banned captive
breeding which means that it only
applies to the San Diego SeaWorld
but that [ __ ] came down whatever that
decision was and it was made official
like within two days of me getting my
jail sentence that's amazing
and I liked it they mad maybe it's such
a coincidence but I like to think that I
got people sort of talking about it you
know like like in the you know thinking
about it and then they're like you know
what [ __ ] those people well you
definitely did you definitely put some
attention on it but there's been some
attention on it for quite a while and
that were these blackfish was the big
worse that was the big one that woke up
a lot of people when they did just
realize like whoa well what would it
what is this place killed SeaWorld for
me forever I used to love it going as a
kid I was always telling you like you're
you're going to watch prisoners you're
going to watch slaves and I don't it's
it's super [ __ ] they're like water
people I mean they really are like as
smart as human beings well you could say
that but some humans are and dolphins
kill a lot of babies right now like
theirs they kill baby dolphins they rape
a lot they're not the best I mean
there's our dicks but not with killer
whales kill dolphins oh yeah yeah and
whales they eat whales alive like it's a
hard [ __ ] world in the ocean the
world the oceans a dog-eat-dog world or
dolphin e-baby world or a whale killer
whale well there has never been an
instance of a killer whale you know the
people that would like to come orcas
that work has never attacked a human in
the wild it's true well we were filming
wild boys we went to Alaska and we like
ran across a pod of orcas and we had
Manny the crazy shark guy you know like
Tarzan looking dude the ride sharks
everywhere he was so jazzed he sees he's
killing these [ __ ] killer whales in
the wild he's like like just dives in to
go swim with them you know like and we
had probably had an inflatable killer
whale there too and like we towed
Pontius like on it you know like try to
like right through it but you can you
swim towards these orcas and and they're
out with you yeah but they have saved
people they've saved drowning people
Baba yeah you know the people who
capsized boats they've actually lifted
them up and helped them there they're
very smart they say that they have
dialects they have like I can tell
they're different accents they they
recognize each other they stay with the
same family for a life that's why it's
so [ __ ] up when they take them away
like you're stealing someone away like a
child away from their mother yes so
[ __ ] dark and when you see those
SeaWorld commercials they're like we
haven't taken orcas from the wild in
over thirty four years that's the
imagine if there was a commercial for
like Nabisco and the Bisco was like we
haven't stolen slaves in over 34 years
the slides that we have we have had them
for a long time that's basically what
they're saying good I grew up with a sea
road in Ohio and it's really weird how
you know growing up they don't teach you
that like hey we captured these guys
that you always kind of thought like oh
they're injured and we help them and
that's why they're here it was always
kind of like oh I like zero because I
like I want to see these dolphins do
good and be better but you know watching
that movie you realize you know it's the
exact opposite they just kind of right
now slavery yeah they say a dolphin has
a cerebral cortex that's 40% larger than
human beings
I believe they don't mean they don't
have the ability to alter their
environment they can't pick things up
and move them around they can't send
emails but they don't have to they live
in a 3d world like they can fly around
in their world I mean they come up for
air but in their world they can go left
right up down they don't need fingers
like it's not necessary so our idea like
what's intelligent it's like if you
can't type something of you
can't build a house your [ __ ] idiot
you know that's how we look at it I just
but but those things that we define as
intelligent when it comes to human
beings are completely unnecessary they
go with the waters warm the fish are
everywhere fish are stupid it's [ __ ]
they swim up to him i jáchym dolphins
probably never starve to death I mean
they're faster than fish I mean I guess
they die of old age but you got to think
like it's less they run out of fish fish
are probably easy as [ __ ] for them to
catch they just swim up and Jack them
it's like food is floating around the
sky imagine if you ever way you went
like there's sandwiches just floating
around if one of you guys hang out with
your homies and grab a sandwich that's
dolphin world but they do do some dark
[ __ ] but they usually do it in the name
of breeding
that's why female dolphins are like
super [ __ ] they're super [ __ ]
because they want to have because the
amount they can't recognize lines of
paternity so they they don't necessarily
know whether or not the baby's theirs so
if they go up to a check and she's got
babies and they have never had sex with
her the women the female dolphins won't
have sex until their baby has reached
like maturity until their baby can swim
away it's like a few years I believe so
when the male's come up to females and
they have babies and they haven't had
sex with the male with the female
they'll sometimes kill the babies so
that she'll have sex with them again ah
it's pretty [ __ ] up Lions do [ __ ] like
that Bears do [ __ ] like that too yeah
that's the other thing the video with
you and the lion freaked yeah okay so
I'm going jail for [ __ ] good cause
man I used to get arrested for [ __ ] up
[ __ ] man you know like drugs and
violence like in Canada I got arrested
for violence what kind of yeah it was it
was assault
like um and we actually ran away from
cops and got away it was on New Year's
Eve when 2003 I want to say it was it
was 2003 turning into 2004 did this big
show and some [ __ ] [ __ ] got on
stage and like snuck up like whatever
and like sucker-punched me while I was
on stage
you know like [ __ ] punch me and so of
course everybody that grabs him and
starts beating the [ __ ] out of them and
and and I'm like and I'm like you know
on the microphone saying
[ __ ] kick-ass you know like you know
China like it started out as an assault
on me but by the time I was like nah
kicks ass and and they're beating him
just all blood like and Preston lacy the
big guy on jackass Heather his
microphone he was like creating the news
for that off mic so he's kind of blood
even from that and then they like they
carried him you know they cared then
they were carrying him away and I like
hauled off and kicked the guy you know
and so like you've got in trouble for
that I did yeah the cops cut were called
and we just I think maybe like ran off
the stage and she's dipped you know I
like and got away but then I was back
you know I'm you know my new tour in
[ __ ] I was in is in Calgary and and
I'm on the I'm on the the Morning News
promoting my shows they said have you
ever been to Calgary before I said oh
yeah like I was I was here and and we
really beat the crap out of this guy and
then we ran from cops and got away like
you in Canada well I'm Canadian I became
Passport
yeah I'm also American Anamosa British
but what yeah my mom was born in Canada
my dad was born in America I was born in
England so I'm all three well you so all
you do is be born in a country like that
and you gotta support your citizen yeah
but then they allow you to be a citizen
of America too correct yeah you can't it
can't be you know it can't be a resident
of more than one place right but you can
be a citizen yeah like I did marry like
Australian chick I'm stoked in New
Zealand would be even better and soon
then you work Quadra right quite a
citizen I'm triple national the thing
was though like I'm some bragging about
like yeah it would beat up this guy and
[ __ ] ran from the cops and then when
I left from that trip
hand over the passport like to the
immigration guy like you know going
through the airport he's like yeah go
ahead and wait in this room and sends my
flag yeah said the cops came
arrested me and the guys and I mean they
held me for like 12 hours or 10 hours or
something and what they say when they
arrested you they said you have an
outstanding warrant which I think it's
pretty funny it's like an outstanding
warrant why'd you let you go after 12
hours because I paid bail like $10,000
bail that's it you have to go back and
go to court I mean it was a misdemeanor
you know whatever like I got it sorted
out from you know like whatever Canada
doesn't play when it comes to assault
though like if you can it is the [ __ ]
toughest country to get into I mean like
everybody gets have you got a drunk
driving arrest or not no I'm like I saw
it I don't I don't know if there was
that big of a deal but but whatever you
know it was great because I was able to
sort of you know like clear away the
wreckage of my past like for all the
fucked-up [ __ ] I've done like I like to
think I've made it all right you know
how about the dude that got spiked on
his [ __ ] head he's fine 50 grand man
Special K threw that 50 grand the first
day that's a it's it's a weird thing
like the Canadian thing like they live
right next door to us so they're gonna
be real careful about like fugitives
sneaking across the border so they're
super strict about any weirdness like
Eddie Bravo Oh a long time ago got
pulled over not even arrested for having
a legal he used to work for a
check-cashing company so he used to take
these bags of cash around with them and
he had a concealed weapons permit and so
he gets pulled over by the cops and he
tells the cops officer I work for a
check-cashing company I have a large sum
of cash and I also have a concealed
weapon and here's here's my permits here
my paperwork and so they take him out of
the car the handcuffed him check his
paperwork through everything seems in
order
you're free to go and they let him go so
every time he goes to Canada they bring
up that every time still on his record
on his record
still I was record it wasn't even an
arrest he pulled they pulled him over
they checked me but
when it involves a gun if it involves
anything where you large amounts of cash
everybody kept tight about but it was it
was all legit it was he worked for a
check-cashing company so he had a total
100% ironclad excuse they let him out I
mean it never brought him to jail they
let him go yeah but still every time he
goes to Canada they check him is hasn't
James had a real hard time because Kevin
James got in a street fight like in like
high school or college or something like
that and got arrested no conviction not
nothing but every time he would go to
Canada when before you're famous we do
the Montreal Comedy Festival together
every time we'd go to Canada they'd [ __ ]
with him you know Australia is the same
way man Australia is like maybe even
harder to get into than Canada and like
Matt and I'm not Australian so when I
when I go to Australia I have to like
feel like a with my visa application I
have to submit my entire criminal record
like my whole history and it's like so
long it's hilarious
like you know there's even a bunch of
stuff I didn't even mention like you
know like beginning arrested all over
the state's this stuff nothing was
really good how many times you've been
arrested there's one in in Philadelphia
like public urination was like I mean
kind of mellows more like funny than
anything and there's my first drunk
driving you should have like those like
four lines and a stripe for five like
counting off the days in prison when I
got last year you know like a year and
half ago or something I did a whole
Australia tour and you know I was I was
like putting it all together and I made
like a youtube video like actually going
through my whole like official thing and
like with all the paperwork yeah my
criminal like my criminal past or
whatever and at the same time to the the
Australian tour promoter wanted need to
have a name for my tour you know like Oh
we'd like to have you know a name for
the tour and so I'm going through my
whole arrest history and so I told him
yeah man it's steve-o guilty as charged
the name of my tour you know and so
that's been the name of my tour
for like a year and a half you know like
if anybody wants to know the name of it
that's what it is every time and now and
and I'm so excited to be here today is
because in like less than three weeks in
Austin Texas I'm taping my first a
comedy special for Showtime
and it's of course called steve-o guilty
as charged
what are you taping it at the Paramount
Theatre in Austin Texas a good spot I've
been there ha did so it's so [ __ ] I
mean I just love Texas my love I love
Texas so much and it's the one place
that I haven't been to with this tour so
it's like another fresh fresh crowd you
know and we're I'm doing on tour are you
doing straight stand-up are you doing
it's it's like a one-man show or like
it's totally stand up it's totally
stories and like on story points
throughout the show like I do like super
[ __ ] up stunts you know like what like
I mean when I come in like I'm gonna
like blast [ __ ] like a 12 pack of soda
cans on my head you know I like until
they're all like busted open what yeah
you just take the cannon it's not open
and you just [ __ ] keep smashing it in
your head and it's gonna be showed up
with all the lights you know like all
the lights and when once was once it
breaks it's like spraying like super
[ __ ] a lot you know and something it
looked out man I'll break like at least
six of them and uh and then whatever
like you know it looks so healthy for
someone who's done so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
to your body like you walk normal
yeah you seem to be your voice a little
raspy but everybody's coming out good
what words come out smooth I appreciated
you know at the top of my show I'm like
you know I got some crowd work and stuff
like and I don't waste any time before I
start [ __ ] bagging on Carlos Mencia
and your crowd work what yeah because
like all I pulled out like I'm one of my
big bits is you know like I'll pull the
the crowd about you know ladies clap it
you've ever received a dick pic from
someone you know and it's like really
likes you know it's like one of my like
you know best like crowd work bids and
you know after I get done like with all
like the back-and-forth with you know
it's just really [ __ ] funny to pull
like you know now like what kind of dick
pics is you get like some guys that you
weren't hooking up with like now clap if
you got a dick pic from a guy that you
were not hooking up with it all and like
less but still a tons of chicks clapping
okay now I eat a clap really loud if he
went on to have sex with that guy you
know like so it doesn't work you know
and then I'd tell him like you know and
I just saw this thing recently and so I
just started doing it like um I say you
know I saw this funny thing online about
dick pics and it was so funny I stole it
you know it was one of these memes where
a girl saying receiving a dick pic from
a guy is just like her cat bringing her
a dead mouse she says she says I can see
that you are very proud and people were
like actually clapping you know and I
say and I said every time I'm like oh my
god I can't [ __ ] like this floors me
getting applause for a joke I told you I
stole I said so much I decided I'm gonna
do a whole [ __ ] bit just out of jokes
I stole I call it the Carlos Mencia bit
I just said really quick because I don't
like the [ __ ] I don't even I'm not
even comfortable doing this but not my
I'll tell you two jokes one you've heard
of one you haven't but I stole them both
I want people to come to Austin so much
cuz like normally I do comedy clubs you
know and like I saw the lines share my
tickets like once I get there you know I
don't do a lot of advance ticket sales I
show up and I get on the radio and
people are always here and then I do
great you know I like I do really well
but in this case for and it's November
21st this month at the Paramount Theatre
in Austin
like I don't have the luxury of waiting
to get there if I can sell tickets
because it's a [ __ ] Showtime comedy
special rather yep that place sold the
[ __ ] out what's the date November 21st
dude will tweet the [ __ ] out of it
ah dude I'm so stoked man thank you yeah
November 21st Paramount Theater you can
like find it at Stevo comm will tweet it
will tweet it will tweet it after this
show is over YouTube notes that he'll be
there okay we'll put in the yeah and
it's gonna be a bunch of people want to
see you smash soda can dude I used to do
it like I used to do it like on comedy
clubs like six times a week
you know I would break like you know
like like one two or three and I was
[ __ ] wake up in the morning and I'd
[ __ ] like a tag on a bed and I'm
walking like [ __ ] diagonally I was
like I've got to stop hitting myself in
the [ __ ] head but yet you're gonna do
it again
I'm gonna do it but yeah that's how many
shows I was doing it like all the time
so you doing it like Wednesday Thursday
right right right right exactly by the
time Sunday yeah yes so in any case I'll
be smashing the cans I do like that you
know I've got like a couple bits like
with the crowd work and then the [ __ ]
you know by the time I'll even tell you
the jokes that [ __ ] thing they're
funny they're the ones I stole for the
Carlos Mencia bit but if you do that
then the people you're right you're
right you're right yeah thank you Joe
listening thank you Joe they listen they
remember they write [ __ ] they're right
but that like you know after after that
then that's like okay now I'm gonna
really get into it and so it's sort of
like I start off you know addressing
like how people have asked me for so
long like how did I get into it how to
jackass [ __ ] start mm-hm
and you know I give like a super
condensed like super hilarious like sort
of [ __ ]
Genesis story of like you know starting
with like me in high school and getting
caught and dealing drugs and
like and you know like going into
college and just [ __ ] up royally I
mean I ever [ __ ] up royally at in
college and not to do in college it was
so bad well within two weeks of class
starting my freshman year I was I was on
final disciplinary probation which is
[ __ ] impressed two weeks yeah I got
my room rate and like they found on
alcohol and weed and [ __ ] and said like
you know so they they relocated me into
another [ __ ] dorm you know and
they're like you were on final
disciplinary probation and like I
climbed up like that broke out a window
and climbed onto the roof and you know
clay there's a radio tower on top of the
roof and I climbed up that and someone
spotted me from the ground and and so
the cops came on the roof and they
kicked me out of the dorms and I was
failing the [ __ ] out of my classes and
and then I just got in a van with this
dude and just took off without him
withdrawing so I got I got in a van with
I failed out I got kicked out and I
dropped out oh my coach I call
overachieving mouthful I know and things
like you know people were like when I
was leaving the University of Miami it's
like well what are you gonna do now and
I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] videotape
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and I'm gonna I'm gonna
be one year was this 93 so you had this
idea in 93 oh yeah I was in and even
then I was like man like I had like
special [ __ ] skills you know like I
had like I was really [ __ ] good at
drinking bong water
and Kara murky it was much very much
said I don't even care how murky it was
if you live a whole life that never
comes out of your mouth you live a good
life right and like I was like I you
know it was Miami so I was like super
they're like blow up class and I'd be
like practicing jumping on the diving
boards at the at the pool and I'm like
I'm never gonna be a diver but if I jump
strictly off of like roofs of like
apartment buildings and [ __ ] into
shallow pools then it's badass so I was
like I got pretty good at that
oh my god like my specialty was like
setting myself on fire with like
hairspray and rubbing alcohol and so at
the point where I'm not even like
[ __ ] five minutes into the show at
this point and I had to say my specialty
was setting myself on fire with
hairspray and rubbing alcohol so I'm
getting at that point demonstrate like
it's camera do you like that at a in the
theater they let you do it in comedy
clubs all the time I kept getting so
hurt like I just like because what I do
is like I'm going to do like kind of
deluxe version for this one like I'm
gonna start with like a can of hairspray
I'm gonna like spray my like all the
hair on my head like heavily with the
hairspray I'm going to climb on top of a
table on the stage and douse my arm with
rubbing alcohol fill my mouth with lamp
oil then I'm gonna click I'm gonna click
a lighter and light my arm on fire like
just the rubbing I'll call my skin's and
the trails all the way up to your hair
well like a drop like from when I pour
it like on the table there'll be a
puddle and so like a drop will stand
fire probably and then so the table will
be on fire my arms on fire and then like
so I'm gonna use my arms and torch when
I do a front-flip
standing on top of the table and
simultaneously as I do the front flip
blow a fireball
like off of my arm like which is a huge
lamp lamp oil goes crazy so like the
lamp oil and as I'm flipping for like
the front flip my head like everything
just goes right through the fire so when
I crash
on the table on my back now my head's on
fire and so then I get and get up and
like kind of like like flail around the
stage with my head on fire and my buddy
comes around and out with a mouthful of
lamp oil and he comes right out to me
and he uses my head as a torch and just
you know blows a [ __ ] huge fireball
off of my head and and then like we'll
figure out how to put me out you know
then we'll figure it out right right I
mean maybe he'll have like a towel or
something because I've gotten like a
towel my bare hands think about it well
I mean it didn't occur to me that they
would freeze had that I was gonna do it
until I already did it a million-plus
people are gonna hear this someone's
gonna tell them all right well then
[ __ ] I better figure it out I've done
it in the [ __ ] thousand places have
you ever let anybody know beforehand on
a podcast did I feel like a [ __ ]
flashback from Calgary coming back it's
like all the times you hit yourself in
the head with sodas you've knocked out a
segment of your brain that's just the
worries I got maybe with you would
definitely have a bunch of people
Authority let the [ __ ] fire marshal
know or whatever do it like this is so
important man I have to do it aren't you
scared that like maybe you'll get really
injured and you can't finish I mean like
really bad and it hurts but it's not
gonna like stop me
you know Wow like half the rest of your
show could be you looking you know like
a steam coming on face movie
it's like it's part of the fun right
being all [ __ ] up yeah I mean I think
it's whatever I mean the crazier the
better you know like I'm in this to
[ __ ] really make an impression
whatever like it's gonna it's gonna go
on and there's just gonna be like so
that's kind of a one-man show but the
thing is like it's also like fully
stand-up man I've been on tour doing
stand-up for five years now yeah I
remember when you first started doing I
was like that's it because you first
started doing it like right around the
time we were getting sober right I had
been sober for like two years when I
really don't into it and that I wasn't
sober yet when I first started oh you
weren't yeah first time I tried it was
2006 oh okay so you took a break and
then came back yeah I mean I just
dabbled in it until I've been sober for
a couple years but that's pretty much
what you do now pretty much yeah now is
being sober does that [ __ ] with your
ability to do a lot of these crazy
stunts well obviously not you know I
would say that I I mean if you're like
sober like you know like deliberately
hurting yourself isn't necessarily
easier but it's like I never did that
because you know wasted I did it because
I'm an attention [ __ ] and sober not
take away the drugs and alcohol I'm
still an attention [ __ ] but you embrace
that
[ __ ] yeah do you why do you think I
haven't [ __ ] tattooed myself on my
back you know like everybody's favorite
topic of conversation is themselves I'm
just like I think that's hilarious and
I'm cool admitting it but it just seems
like if you were [ __ ] up on drugs and
you made this career of like getting
hammered and and going out and doing
wild crazy stunts that got you injured
and then you cut out the getting [ __ ]
up part right but you're still injuring
yourself well I mean injuring myself
isn't like isn't as much of it you know
I mean sure I still do it I don't carry
what's the most injured you've ever
gotten I threw myself off of a balcony
at the University of Miami after I
dropped out and then I came back and
just lived there
even though I wasn't allowed to there's
like a keg party and I was trying to
like impress this fat chick and that was
on the balcony like but I had taken too
many pills and drank too much booze and
I'm telling this girl this was in I
think it was Janie I was January of 1995
and I'm telling this girl said I'm gonna
be like a [ __ ] super rad stuntman and
we're on the second floor balcony I tell
her like you know like okay like I'm
gonna be like this [ __ ] gnarly
stuntman like picture this I command
like like there's a fight on the balcony
you're right and like I get punched and
I'm like pretending I get punched and I
just throw myself off the balcony now I
used to throw myself off the balconies
all the time
but not when I was that [ __ ] up and
not when I was trying to pretend that I
had been punched and so my whole my
whole game plan were like the way I
would do it I did did it different I
didn't catch the bottom with my hand and
then let myself go I just spun over the
railing and so I spun over the railing I
landed on my [ __ ] face on the bottom
huh and I broke I burn I have the
cat-scans they're so gnarly like I broke
my my cheekbone
I broke seven teeth I had ten stitches
in my chin a concussion and a broken
wrist and that's actually pretty good
considering you fell onto what concrete
and I was landing that landed there and
I was [ __ ] face down from where I'm
from where I needed the ten stitches I
had like a pool of blood like growing I
was facedown and I'm not even [ __ ]
twitching a finger at all I'm just like
there's just blood pooling you know and
and I'm not moving and everyone's like
thinks I'm probably dead but my buddies
were like they're like man if he's not
dead he's gonna need that weed in his
pocket I had like kind weed you know
they like [ __ ] proper good weed in
one pocket and like swag weed in the
other and and they you know pulled it
off put it out and and and in the
morning I knew my mom was like I didn't
even remember landing I gotta remember
anything you know and they called the
ambulance whatever that came and and
then in the morning like I woke up and I
was so [ __ ] up it was
I knew my mom was on a cruise ship in
like the Caribbean but I but I told him
I said oh I needed to call my mom and
they said of course but what I did was I
called my buddies down at the University
of Miami I said hey I'm gonna [ __ ]
leave out the [ __ ] emergency room
entrance right now come scoop me up and
I broke out to the hospital in my in my
gown okay and they came and picked me up
and I went back to the spot and I stood
like right over like the pool of blood
and I tried to pound a beer but I
couldn't because it hurts too bad and I
couldn't eat or anything and I was like
like my sinuses would like fill with
blood and then I would like Hocking you
know like you hock a loogie and I mom
and then spit it out and it was just
blood loogies for like two weeks I tried
to eat applesauce and I couldn't even
[ __ ] eat applesauce because I was so
busted up and so the applesauce a bowl
of applesauce sat next to my bed just
with blood loogies in it I had broke my
wrist too so I had um the cast on my
wrist for like whatever you have it on
for six weeks and my mom like sort of
felt bad for me because my I broke seven
teeth and so my [ __ ] all my front
teeth are all busted out and she knew I
was a [ __ ] you know which teeth like
it was it was like my front one of my
front ones and then there was one that
didn't break one on the other side of
that one did break so it looked extra
bad right and my mom like felt bad for
me she like sort of had like you know
felt bad for me you know she's sort of
an enabler it's here so she said a
dentist appointment for me to get my
teeth fixed
you know like and she's gonna pay for it
and I still got the cast of my wrist and
and the night before the [ __ ] dentist
appointment or I'm gonna get my teeth
fixed is when I get [ __ ] arrested for
my first drunk driving you know and like
and so they [ __ ] take me into
miami-dade [ __ ] county jail and I'm
in the holding cell there and and one of
the [ __ ] like correctional officers
in the jail except my [ __ ] car
and says that caste is a potential
weapon you know like like like if I get
into a fight in the holding cell now I'm
gonna have an unfair advantage because
I've got this cast on my arm so they're
like you can't be in this [ __ ]
holding cell you have to go in to this
gnarly [ __ ] like crazy [ __ ] you
know insult with like all the people are
in here for the longest stretch of time
oh god you know and this is the first
thing I had to do was go and take a
forget naked and take a [ __ ] shower
in the back of this big cell with all
these bunk beds and all these [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] and like this sucks man
I called my mom and I was like mom you
know like you know I'm in jail you know
and she's like she's like what you know
like she says I'm not bailing you out
unless you go door-to-door straight to
rehab and I'm like okay so I went to
rehab like in 1995 and and I remember
these [ __ ] guys like that when the
counselor says like yeah you know like
95% of all alcoholics like died drunk of
causes related directly to alcohol is I
mean I like most people like they don't
get sober you know like and I'm sitting
there thinking man this guy's telling me
like if I had like really wanted to get
sober I got a 5% chance I'm like [ __ ]
that so I stayed loaded like I just
resigned myself to being loaded forever
and it wasn't until like 13 years later
I've silly gosh so him saying that so
it's me [ __ ] wasted but what it did
really wasn't what it did was it just
made me not like get sober until I was
really ready you know I think it's what
made you really ready well I mean [ __ ] I
got in like Knoxville called an
intervention I mean like that's when you
know your fucked-up interventionist uh
what was going on that he had a step in
well I had this like [ __ ] massive
mass email thing and I was like
broadcasting my downward spiral in like
[ __ ] real-time
like you know 200 the most like you know
influential [ __ ] people in the
entertainment industry whose who had the
misfortune of giving me their info you
know and it was just like more [ __ ] up
and it's kept getting worse and worse
and and and I got arrested for like you
know felony cocaine possession there was
another one of my [ __ ] arrests
let's felony cocaine possession you have
a well there's no such thing as
misdemeanor cocaine possession that's
even like a little bit yeah but I got a
victory I got you know arrested you know
like this is when I had like my neighbor
in this apartment building I lived in
was always calling the cops because I
deserved it
like he was a lawyer and I'm like an
[ __ ] and I'm always making all this
noise so the cops are always coming but
typically they would get to my apartment
and they bestowed they'd be like oh no
way Steve oh cool man have a good night
and sound like David so they would take
off you know there's this guy [ __ ]
his life was misery because wasn't like
because I was such a [ __ ] you know
loaded [ __ ] I'm thought my [ __ ]
drugs and [ __ ] being wasted
I was just became particularly mad at
him for always calling the cops on me so
I like I'd like [ __ ] take like a
baseball man like powdered or whatever
like [ __ ] you call the cops you know
like no and and I was like I was in
pound I was like you know I was like
pounding on the wall that separated our
apartments like all the time it's like
how you like that [ __ ] you know how do
you like that and I pounded on the walls
so hard that I [ __ ] actually pounded
a hole through the wall where I'm
looking into his apartment
Haitao see his apartment aside I punched
well the thing was that I pounded enough
and then I took a broomstick and [ __ ]
just pounding pounding baton til I got
through you know so now he calls the
cops and they actually have to arrest me
for four
whatever [ __ ] vandalism you know like
it was a misdemeanor but I've been I've
now vandalized his property by pounding
through the wall
so they come to arrest me and this time
it doesn't matter if they're stoked or
whatever like you know and I'm so blown
out on [ __ ] ketamine and I don't know
what's going on and I got [ __ ] bag of
cocaine in my pocket and like and I'm
and I open up the door like I got I'm
shirtless I have no shoes on and a bag
of cocaine in my pocket and I'm out of
my mind and they're like hey we're
taking it to jail because we have to
arrest you for vandalism and like it's
gonna be cold and so I'd like as a
courtesy like you can go in there and
put on a shirt and put on some shoes I
thought my [ __ ] shirt [ __ ] surgeries
I mean well that would have been like
the perfect opportunity for me to go in
take the bag of cocaine out of my pocket
and I put on lead out like it was a
perfect opportunity but I'm like [ __ ]
that yeah so they take me to jail with
no shirt no shoes and a [ __ ] and I
get reared they've go to your property
you know that when they process you
under jail and so they pull out the bag
of cocaine and they really they really
at the jail oh my god so I'm in there
for like three days or something and
it's on the news and apartment buildings
[ __ ] over me even though I've rented
four apartments in the building because
one was a skate park one was like sort
of like my my buddies then when my one
guy edited my videos and stuff this kind
of an office had this like assistant
chick oh this is such a [ __ ] joke I
mean her job was just to tell people
that she couldn't find me and I
constantly changed my flights because I
always miss my flights you know she was
like a travel agent at best but I had an
apartment for her and then I had my
bachelor pad so it was four and still
the [ __ ] apartments like get the [ __ ]
out
were you ready for apartments and then
you still get evicted like that's when
you know you [ __ ] up well especially
when one of them's escaped part right I
know but it was it was like it was like
neck then the next to it on one side was
a [ __ ] like Russian hooker operation
oh so they were complaining you know
they're dudes coming in to [ __ ] these
hookers all day long where did you live
I've specific right across the street
from rock'n'roll arouse oh right in the
midst yeah I mean right on the part of
Sunset place to live and the lawyers
live in there closer I don't know that I
ever actually met him like man I mean
yelling like through the door like
whatever maybe like a summer I wouldn't
recognize did you feel like you want to
go back and apologize to him I tried I
tried I actually had his email and you
know I reached out to him and I said hey
like yeah it would mean a lot to me it's
like we could meet up and you know and
he just declined so I had to respect
that you know but yeah that's kind in an
email he declined he declined to me yes
so I just sort of like when you're in
that situation you want to go through
and make things right right you have to
respect that you can't like be
persistent in them so to make it right
to that guy like you know it's called a
living amends where I sort of I'm not
gonna do that to anybody else and it's a
party thing about rehab it's just like
basically a thing about life you know
but um that's something that they asked
you to do like when you're you own to
rehab their rights it would be
considered step 9 of the 12 steps you
know we made direct amends wherever
possible except when to do so would
injure them or others so yeah so that's
part of the deal and now I can finally
get out of jail and I come back and
there's a [ __ ] eviction notice on my
on my door you know like get the [ __ ]
out within three days oh actually that
there was that yeah I got an end like I
had all drugs in my apartment so like I
get back and like there's the eviction
notice but like I just go straight for
like the vials of ketamine I had like
two or three more vials Academy
hooked him up in the microwave you know
I find I went digging through cook them
up no Mike how do you how do you handle
ketamine well yeah I mean it's best I
never just like injected [ __ ] I just
never got that far but you just cook it
in the microwave and it evaporates like
the maybe water I don't know and you're
left with like the the plate it's like
crusted to the plate and then you scrape
it up with like a card and then what you
do with that started snort it ya know
how did you how did you get started on
ketamine cuz ketamine is like a like
that is my favorite man first time I
tried it I don't think so Neal Brennan
he's the co-creator of the Chappelle
show stand-up comic funny guy he's been
taking ketamine treatments for
depression it's one of them yeah yeah
yeah it's one of the more recent
treatments for depression why they've
been well because it resets the way you
any intense psychedelic experience and
ketamine even though it's a tranquilizer
is thought of as a pretty and really
that's how you look at it but did you
have like outta body experiences or any
experiences where you felt like you went
into another dimension and trip you know
the K hold experience some of the
experiences I had with ketamine like
person I got weed depth perception like
wave [ __ ] looks like some fear and
loathing [ __ ] you know like you're not
like you know about it like I've been I
remember like like my [ __ ] feet are
like 30 feet away in a hotel room in
London
there's no with just way too much of the
[ __ ] and like and at one point the whole
hotel room just started free-falling I
mean my god well nothing is like looking
up like I could actually see like a like
kind of an elevator shaft type deal that
it was falling through you know like it
was just the hotel room started
free-falling and I'm like just thinking
whoa and I remember being so stoked I
was thinking I'm ever thinking
Jim Morrison doesn't have [ __ ] on me
like I'm so good at being a drug addict
like but um so yeah I've been cooking up
the ketamine and whatever and I packed
is it coming but it's becoming a liquid
form because Michelle
so that initially where you would stick
need a limit on shooting to a cat
usually I think horse as much yeah horse
uh-huh
I mean PCP started out as an anesthetic
that was the idea for it but yeah within
like two hours of being of walking out
of jail I have my buddy videotaping me
I'm jumping up and down on the roof of a
parked car screaming god is the Sun and
like this squad of like security guards
that comes over and like you know what's
going on you know like I mean it's
amazing that I didn't go right back into
jail for another Hey pockets full of
drugs you know and so there but I mean
and I did that bender lasted for I don't
know like maybe 24 hours and now I've
got you know my three days is like and
I've got one more day I got to be out of
the apartment so I send the mass email
list I'm going to say hey you know Megan
with all the jackass guys on it but of
course 200 like high-power people in
Hollywood need to know this that like
hey knocks on guys you know I I got to
be out of my apartment tomorrow and I'm
not [ __ ] leaving my apartment I don't
want to [ __ ] leave here until I jump
out of my bedroom window you know it
should be like a 25-foot drop onto the
sidewalk and I need you guys to bring
something for me to land on preferably a
hot tub I already like to put a hot tub
like and cannonball into and out of my
bedroom window and and in my sliding
glass door in the living room I could
pull it open and I wanted to put it like
a ramp
in the living room and ride a motorcycle
lay off the ramp through the sliding
glass door and jump onto the roof did
you imagine if you own an apartment
that's not some explaining me bad
weather the sliding glass door then
because he's like just like a 3-foot gap
to the fielding next door like that part
was a gimme
yeah but so I said like knocks I see you
guys come over bring a [ __ ] camera
this is we're gonna [ __ ] start
filming like jackass three and like you
know get over here c'mon man before I
leave we're gonna do my eviction party
stunts and and so basically I scheduled
my own intervention knocks out reached
out to dr. Drew who was on the list the
email list he's like hazy
he was like about to die and dr. Drew
said yeah you're right you know he said
get over there and [ __ ] if you got a
timeout put him in the trunk like take
him to the hospital oh and that the
other part I said if you don't bring
anything for me to land on I'm [ __ ]
jumping anyway I promise I'm ready to
die so they printed that up it was like
I mean threatening my own life which
qualified me for the 5150 law where you
can lock someone into a psychiatric ward
Wow
so they came over to for my intervention
and and like they're like it wasn't like
the kind of intervention where like
where they ask if you're willing to
accept help you know it's like like
we're taking you to the psych ward this
is what's gonna happen if you don't like
it we're gonna kick your ass and take
you anyway so they take me to the psych
ward for the the 72-hour hold which is
like you know everybody's been on that
like you know the whole deal but the
thing was when we got there I was like
spitting on people I was just like not
[ __ ] cool and like I was trying to
throw [ __ ] around and you know like I
was like when I remember because what I
thought I was gonna like calmly explain
that it was misunderstanding and be out
of there but like what happened was they
had the emails printed out where I'm
like saying I'm ready to die you know
and so like they had me I wasn't talking
my way out of it once I realized I
wasn't getting out of it then I'm like
[ __ ] you know I grab go to take a chair
and throw it and like I get [ __ ]
tackled by like these orderly dudes you
know and they slam me on to this [ __ ]
I stretch her like bed thing with straps
on it and like someone jabs a needle in
my butt cheek and then I just straight
took them back like that Thorazine [ __ ]
man like is gnarly man I just held you
down and whacked you with that yeah they
just held me down and [ __ ] jam to my
butt cheek and I was out dude and then I
woke up from my nap and and I'm in it
was so funny though it was at
cedars-sinai Italians you know like
what's that mean aliens just the mental
health didn't like division or whatever
so like they have they've got they had
two wings of the of the psych ward
they're like one like they've got the
standard-issue harmful to yourself or
others you know like committed for the
involuntary psychiatric hold then
they've got the something outs like the
extraordinarily you know like the
extraordinarily qualifying individuals
you know and that's you there's
something out swing yeah so it said they
had me on to something else wing and
like whoa yeah and like my roommate was
like [ __ ] like like like hiding in
the closet from like [ __ ] demons oh
dude it was I mean I've been hearing
voices for like a couple years you know
oh dude oh you're the best
I have angels and demons you know like
someone would tell me like you're
worthless you need to die and I would be
like trying to suffocate myself to death
you know really well yeah I mean not
like with anything I'm just holding my
breath right but that was the whole
thing was I was hearing voices because I
was huffing so much nitrous oxide and
while while you're doing ketamine while
I was doing cocaine I never smoke this
joint just [ __ ] relax you make me
feel so much better about myself I used
to watch you watch intervention so that
I could feel better
yeah and I'm worried about your health
more than I'm worried about like you
overdosing I'm worried you're over it's
it's a slow deterioration of your fiber
yeah like the stuff that keeps you
together you talking to me I'm fine now
I am right now I feel like I just worked
out something else worried like people
are like the not people one guy I
remember one guy like [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] ground and was like breakdancing
in it like trying to like dude he was in
school with [ __ ] like spirit around this
is in the room with you no no that was
in the hallway it's break yeah I mean it
looked like his breakdancing but he was
like he took a [ __ ] means trying to
smear it around as much as he could
it just looked like dancing because
because I was so I was so belligerent
think they changed my status from fifty
one fifty to fifty to fifty which meant
they like like 5150 is three days 50 to
52 weeks so they had me for two weeks
and like after like four days then they
made me over to the regular psych ward
and like I was in there and this guy who
is like a [ __ ] he says his heroin
addicts and he's a patient and like he's
got this book about alcoholism and it's
like dude that you have you really like
this book can really help you like you
need this book and I'm like why is it
[ __ ] heroin addicts giving me a book
about alcoholism when we're both like on
suicide watch and a psych ward yeah like
what's the deal and I was like at the
point I was like I'm like dude I can't I
can't get sober I couldn't you know I
was I honestly felt like like nine of
thought like I mean like just core
belief you know that like if I could
have ever gotten sober
like I was past that point I was too far
down the line I was a write-off a lost
cause and like so I just you know like
from when the [ __ ] first time I was
in rehab you know like there's no chance
and so like one night I couldn't sleep
and I like just open this [ __ ] stupid
book like not to find a solution but
straight up to kill time you know that's
all I'm trying to do I'm reading it it's
talking about like you know like
hopeless alcoholics determined to die
and this and that and then like they
they become like you know they get
better or whatever you know they become
like the finest men you could me and I'm
like just remember reading and thinking
like dude what it's saying is like the
more hopeless the more [ __ ] up you are
the better the chances for recovery
which is actually really fully well why
is that because if you have like any
inkling like that like you can manage it
that you could get better that you could
stop on your own then you're just
straight-up not a candidate yeah that's
the rock bottom fearing pretty much and
it's it's it's true like if you feel
like you got it or it's not that big
because I write write write he's for me
like step one we admitted we were
powerless over alcohol you know her
drugs or whatever the case may be like
like would like and and that like that
I've successfully did you know like I
can't do it I'm [ __ ] powerless and so
that's like the first step that's like
the prerequisite and so it's like I
don't know and then these guys come in
and talk about alcoholism and I wouldn't
have [ __ ] never listen to a word they
said but they like you know but I was
locked up in a psych ward and so I did
and I'm like you know thinking there's
nothing I could do about it but they
told their stories and how they lived
and I'm like oh these guys can do it you
know and and so I was just like my life
is a [ __ ] mess I was in the sacred
long enough to be like okay my life's a
[ __ ] mess it's time and I went to
rehab and so you've been clean from 11
and a half years just from that moment
on from the Wow and as been any moments
were you tempted to go off the wagon
I mean sure but like not like I went
from there like door to door into like a
rehab you know and I remember like
because I knew from the [ __ ] back in
the day like the whole 95 out
of alcoholics don't get sober like the
guy who was in charge of the rehab and
back then it was dr. drew I could he was
he was the the chemical dependency
director of this hospital in Pasadena
and and I was a nice place to go
Pasadena yeah and I told you I said I
said hey man you know I'm like right out
fresh out of the psych ward like you
know and I was such a [ __ ] character
I was like an atom like dude I know that
like I know that you know the odds are
not in my [ __ ] favor I know like I
don't want to waste my time I'm gonna do
this I want to get right so I told you
however long you recommend that I stay
here I want to stay significantly longer
because I want to give myself like you
know I want to get myself an advantage
he said that's great you know but like
don't stay here more than 30 days if
you're really serious go into like a
sober living you know like a halfway
house kind of a deal
and and so I did man I did everything
that was [ __ ] people don't mean I did
like all the [ __ ] recovery [ __ ] that
they talked about I did it all and I
wind that [ __ ] sober living and I
stayed there and so I had two two full
years of sobriety I was filming where
you stayed in sober living for three
years while I was bouncing around
treatment like for six months you know
because I was having a tough time with
it I just stayed in [ __ ] treatment
when you say bouncing around treatment
well I I did 30 days there then I went
into like a sober living that doubled it
was like it was like sort of mid-level
care so like I was free to go at night
as long as I'm home by curfew
but all day long right we had all of our
little groups and like like you know
structured rehab activities how much is
all the [ __ ] cost my god expensive it
was stupid
like the 30 days is I gotta grand oh my
god what the [ __ ] and I didn't even
necessarily know that so you pay for all
this I paid for with my own money
oh my god so you're just burning through
your savings while you're in there God
so six months it's better than the
[ __ ] $300,000 I spent on [ __ ]
suing like my these [ __ ] people I
knew I was gonna get nothing out of he
spent 300 grand suing people that you
knew you were gonna get nothing out
my back cat like these guys that I had a
distribution deal with my God my back
catalogue of DVDs but whatever that's
not worth anything it was just a
straight resentment [ __ ] oh I see I just
wanted to [ __ ] their lives yeah I know
that I did it
rehab is a better investment yeah so so
while you're in there are you working
hell no I no [ __ ] burned all my
bridges man you know like I'm doing
anything with jackass and like anything
else I had going on like I had a TV show
that which was really like did well in
the ratings but I was such a [ __ ]
nightmare that they cancelled it just on
the grounds that they did not want to
[ __ ] with me I had the spot right after
Monday Night Raw the wrestling on the
USA Network Wow I came on immediately
after and I kept like a [ __ ] whopping
percentage of their viewers she was name
is show doctor steve-o I went around in
a [ __ ] modified ambulance with a hot
chick and a [ __ ] 365 pound black like
football player driver dude just trying
to deal with safai America one was he at
a time how are you trying to get them to
do I would accept like its submissions
where people would be like dr. Steve oh
I need your help like I you know I'm a
wussy like this is my unique case and I
would prescribe for them some kind of
like outrageous like jackass [ __ ] to
make them come out of their shell or
like it was good man like I did a great
job problem was as soon as the camera
stopped rolling I fell off from the
radar except for my like it was buna
memory their production company like my
army that started like openly attacking
like John Murray why on my for 200
people because he wasn't like pay
somebody's one of my buddies something I
wanted them to get paid for which they
did more than obligated to [ __ ] pay
in the first place but I'm trying to
ruin his reputation with like all these
you know on my [ __ ] crazy email list
and that was what kill that was what
killed the show despite the fact that it
was like number one is [ __ ] timeslot
oh my god
so I didn't have that [ __ ] to get to
distract me from my recovery so you are
doing you're just doing I don't think
recovery not so how do you spend your
days like when you're doing that well I
mean when you're in rehab rehab like you
got like [ __ ] structure [ __ ] all day
long like what cuz I mean what do you do
I mean like different kind of groups
like they take out various kinds of
meetings you know like you got like
[ __ ] like a little therapy bits like
you know whatever it's basically like
summer camp it's just everything is
geared towards teaching how to stay
sober all day long yeah well how much
can they teach you about staying so I'm
confused
yeah but it means go on for two years
oh no no the first 30 days it's like
teaching you like coping mechanisms keep
you occupied and drilling into your head
that you can do this and right and like
38 slow process but like it was great
for me to stay and sort of in that
environment for two years because
because then I'm like undisciplined
[ __ ] you know by the end of it I
was so like used to like being up by
9:00 a.m. with my bed made like pissing
into [ __ ] plastic cups like at random
you know twice a week like scrubbing the
toilet when it's my turn to scrub the
toilet you know like keeping everything
you know and and and I did that when I'm
filming jackass 3d I'm like oh yeah like
I gotta go [ __ ] get launched into the
[ __ ] sky and a porta potty full of
dog [ __ ] I might be a little bit late
for curfew tonight you know like or
whatever you know like was curfew what
time I'm the one the weekdays it was
10:00 and then on the weekends it was
11:00 or 12:00
what or maybe not I think it was 11:00
on the weekdays and 12:00 on the weekend
I think it's hilarious that after a
certain time of night like they think
you're just gonna get whacked
well I mean what happened stay up we
can't go to a diner you know what do you
it saved my life man if I can save my
life big time and I'm so [ __ ] stoned
about it
so just the the schedule the rigid
schedule the routine the structure the
structure did you enjoy it in there did
you have fun you meet nice people I mean
I remember it pretty well my roommate it
was cool and like he snored which was
like the [ __ ] greatest thing ever
because I knew when it was cool to
jackoff you know like the sweet sounds
of snoring yeah jacking off with a guy
in the room but if he's snoring
it's totally cool right yeah I mean that
helps a lot if he didn't have a tougher
time so are you allowed to have
relationships were in there are you
supposed to like steer clear that thing
that can sort of distract you I mean
there's no like hard and fast rule about
that like they say like avoid getting in
a relationship in your first year I got
in the first year yeah I got into a
relationship I mean I had like what if
you found the perfect girl
yeah sorry [ __ ] my sobriety it happens
just not like you know like
relationships gone sideways is like the
number one [ __ ] thing that makes
people get loaded oh right that makes
sense yes so it's good that I kind of
like you know just worry about your
sobriety but I had seven months and I
got in a relationship with a chick who
had like one year it was cool lasted for
like ten months so when you're in there
you're in there for 30 days this is the
hardcore version and then you go from
the 30 days to like a living situation
and now how is that is that like a house
like how's that work it was like an
apartment complex at that point so it's
in a part you got your own apartment
then yeah but I stay Park no no
skatepark yeah that was
think I was a man I used to have [ __ ]
for apartments in one building now I got
four dudes and one apartment so you had
to live with other people you know
there's two bedroom apartment and two
guys nature what yeah why is that the
deal because they want to make sure
you're not alone by yourself yeah do
deviations I mean perhaps you know I
guess that's kind of the deal but like
now what happened they're like and we
would have groups from like you know
eight or nine in the morning until 2:00
in the afternoon and then you're free to
go and and I would be like skateboarding
or whatever like trying to film some
wacky [ __ ] or whatever you know like I
didn't do like much like like in a
professional sense and I was working
with inna I was working on all this like
12-step [ __ ] you know so like I get like
you know we do like the the searching
and fearless moral inventory we're like
we go through like you know basically
like what have we done that like that we
feel like a list of resentments make a
list of fears and we make a list of [ __ ]
we feel guilty about it's basically how
it works and like you know I started off
with just the [ __ ] I felt guilty about
and I'm like oh like I was basically
wrote a list of like the [ __ ] that I
felt like you know the most terrible
about and when when I went through it
like and this is like Tony ones in
recovery like avoid like making this
mistake I treated it like I was just
like you know putting myself on trial
for being a bad person and like you know
the whole point is just to figure out
like what I'm here and you take an
inventory and like you discard what's
not helpful and you can keep what is you
know you just discontinue [ __ ] that
doesn't serve you but I'm like no I'm a
terrible person I did this and this and
this and this and then I'm like ah [ __ ]
you know and like I was just kind of
like went in like a gnarly depression
and felt like I'd [ __ ] I don't
deserve to live you know like whatever
and like I've [ __ ] checked myself
into the psych ward number two you know
while you were in recovery
yeah I had thought you were going over I
had like three months of sobriety and I
went to one of my meetings and I was
like I was like why all the work I'm
putting into my [ __ ] recovery on all
I feel like I'm getting out of it is
self-hatred I feel like I just can't
get myself to the [ __ ] I've done I
[ __ ] hate myself you know and this all
came about from just doing an inventory
on your past pretty much yeah I just had
sad like it says in some of the
literature man it says it like you know
the inventory process will like you know
bring about like self loathing for a lot
of people when we take an honest look at
like the [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] that we
became like that's like a not an
uncommon side-effects now like what what
sort of tools they give you to to look
at your past but not not be angry
yourself not judge yourself well I mean
I don't know I'm helping guys get sober
I try and tell them look man this isn't
a process of putting you on trial man
this is just [ __ ] figuring out what
to stop doing no and that's the best
thing I can say about it but when I was
in that second psych ward like you know
I was like like I wrote I wrote some
letters to people who have felt the most
[ __ ] up about what I'd done you know
and like and it actually kind of turned
around where I was like you know I was
like - today I'm [ __ ] so thankful for
the [ __ ] that I did that I felt that bad
about because like no longer is it like
oh I don't deserve to live because I did
that and like for me today
it's like I'm [ __ ] desperate to not
be that [ __ ] [ __ ] anymore you know
and so it turned into you know and like
when I first went in I was like the kind
of thought like man this is gonna be my
new thing I'm gonna get sober and like
you know I'm gonna be like you know the
world's gonna kind of owe me I'm gonna
revive my career a little bit but once I
got through that point of like you know
sort of the the [ __ ] you know the dust
settling and me being able to me being
confronted with what I had turned into
then it wasn't even about what can I get
out of it you know it was just about I
don't want to be that [ __ ] guy anymore
and so I came out of that second rehab
or that second psych ward and I was so
desperate to not be that [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] anymore and I was like dude I'm
starting over and I went into the
[ __ ] like I went into another rehab
like the [ __ ] like God the hardcore
you know and I was just like I'm doing
this to be and I like I had my
priorities straight you know and then I
was there for
two days and I've been said by the time
I finish that it was six months and then
I went into like the regular sober
living and so that there's a lot of
[ __ ] money you're spending here yeah
the last rehab was seven seventy five
hundred and per month so at least high
but yeah it [ __ ] it was like thirty
grand that second rehab I don't really
the second psych ward I spent a lot of
money on it man what are the guys that
you were in the apartment with what
those guys do for a living that they get
afford to live in this shirt I paid the
rent and I paid him each like a thousand
bucks a month it's nothing
why'd you pay him money for what well
one guy was just said that like he was
on call to edit whatever footage like
that you know that that I wanted edited
like to help me broadcast my downward
spiral basically you know like I put
some really upsetting videos so the
people that you were living in the
assisted situation like this is post the
the major rehab right you were in the
major rehab for 30 days and then the
apartments different levels of rehab
yeah like yeah and and I wound up like
back and yeah I mean it was in the hole
at one point I was in the house for a
while and sharing a bedroom with the guy
who snored and you know and I and and
you know at the end I was in the
apartment but it was all the same deal
what did these guys do for a living that
they could afford to like take all this
time off of what the the sober living
situation was like you know like that
was like 1,000 bucks a month and that
you know covers like your meals as well
oh so it's kind of more cost-effective
than if you're gonna try and find an
apartment or anything like that and in
the sober living situation it's like
these guys work during the day
and then would come there and stay with
you if you don't work you have to do a
certain number of hours of service work
so I would volunteer at a nursing home
whoa yeah there was dope man like I
would just go ahead go [ __ ] hang out
with old people and I'd call the bingo
numbers yeah and then and then I would
like go and [ __ ] move
paramount like oh yeah guys I'm not
gonna be able to call bingo tomorrow
because I'm gonna be like drinking a fat
guy's sweat so when did it feel like you
were free of the monkey you know when I
was like never mind never never
right now you're not free I mean
whenever like I just have like a way
that I love my life you know that I
still stay connected it's like a fridge
man you know like if you unplug the
fridge and then everything and it's
gonna go rotten you know like you gotta
[ __ ] stay plugged in which means that
like these things that that we do to
stay sober like you just [ __ ] keep
like what kind of things
well like helping other people stay
sober is like the biggest thing you know
you know like I you help you take people
through their 12-step and who are these
people that you take through and do you
know them I mean whatever like you meet
them sort of in the community you know
like they'll ask you like will you be my
sponsor and so when you have a sponsor
they call you up in the middle of the
night hey I'm thinking about doing
heroin like that kind of thing talk
about that it's better to call before
you do it then after right because
there's no point in talking to a load of
dude and how often do you do this like
how often you work with people I mean it
depends like most guys like aren't like
that active where they actually really
call a lot but like you know I I'm
always starting a guy you know there's
always guys I'm starting off no and and
just very few of them stick with it
where they get like the guys I've taken
all the way through the steps there's
been two two-letter how many oh my god
so out of a hundred people two of them
have become totally sober I mean they've
been like to say totally sober I mean
you're totally sober as long as you know
you're not loaded right
totally like you are right now like
you're going through the steps but then
he's drinking again so you know I got
one I got one guy that's been all the
way through the steps that's still in do
you think are you one of those people
who thinks that if you were
junkie that you have to be sober forever
like you can't you can't go back to like
you say if you had a heroin problem
you can't drink they say once you become
a pickle you never go back to being a
cucumber so yeah like like there's no if
I pick up a drink or a drug I'm [ __ ]
if I decided I'll pick up exactly where
I left off but I'm and all I want is
like to make sure I'm doing enough drugs
that people are walking around my
[ __ ] apartment my house who are not
actually there I know people that we
used to be like heroin addicts that can
have beer they could smoke a little way
they can get away with it man then then
power to that's dangerous
why is it dangerous though I mean
they're if they're free of it like okay
here's a perfect example Anthony
Bourdain he was a heroin addict he was a
junkie full-on you still like to have a
beer he likes to doesn't drink at home
Perry I think is like that no you can't
have heroin hey man power to him but for
you it's not the way that my family is
structured they're my lineage like dad
was like a broken mold of his fam dad
comes from a line of like academics like
phd's scholars theologians zoologists
like and he broke the mold of his family
by becoming a businessman and a super
successful one at that mom's side of the
family
everybody is alcoholic drug addict
gambler suicide how'd your mom and dad
meet I'm partying she was super hot you
know but yes so like everybody everybody
my mom's side of the family is either
dead or dying from alcoholism I would
say me and my cousins I guess I don't
know my one cousins a mortician yeah I
went to clown con of itself I went to
Clown College he went to mortician
school at the same time what's Clown
College
Ringling Brothers and Barnum & Bailey
Clown College for real what do you do
this is an exploding shoe
what like when I was like you know I
said I left the University of Miami I
wanted to become a crazy stunt man right
now and all I really accomplished like
with that you know even with all my
crazy skills is drinking bong water like
I couldn't get a job like and in South
she's like homeless for three years just
getting arrested and [ __ ] hospital and
it's almost for three years well I was
couch surfer for three years I had the
government test money or to try to test
drugs on me for money what yeah and by
me everything they do medical studies
for like maybe medical studies for
whatever you know like if it's gonna
come in contact with the human body like
if it's a toothpaste or something they
gotta do a medical study but if it's a
toothpaste you're not gonna get paid
[ __ ] if it's [ __ ] drugs for pigs and
cows then based on how dangerous the
study is the more money again and so I
wouldn't sign up for to have drugs for
pigs and cows testing on me with which I
which I recently found out the drugs was
banned jesus [ __ ] christ he's like
this was in like 19 in January of 94
you're like a house that you like you
get to the back whoa this the last door
hold on Jesus a whole nother house yeah
it was like they they want like a you
know 1994 like whatever the January of
94 and then they wanted to pass this
drug through the FDA called RAC dopamine
hydrochloride and the goal of that they
didn't know much about it except they
knew that it would make the cattle like
more lean like it wouldn't like increase
the muscle mass decrease the fat so in
but it would work the opposite way of
steroids somehow and like that was so
that they could appeal to a more kind of
health-conscious and market they could
sell like leaner meat you know less fat
but the thing is that if it's going to
become legal then like by the virtue of
the fact that when people eat the meat
they're going to get like a minor trace
of this drug and then in you know the
meat now they have to not only test the
drug on people but they have to test
like how much can the people withstand
so like they knew that it was gonna like
increase our heart rates like you know
and so what the target for the study was
to give it to us until somebody in the
study had their resting heart rate like
laying down resting I'm like 150 beats a
minute like and it turned out that I had
like the [ __ ] most badass heart in
the study like like the only time I went
over 100 was when the guy like
monitoring my heart with like the
ultrasound thing the you know like did
they show the baby on the screen like he
was like Tommy stories about like
killing people in Vietnam or some [ __ ]
like you know yeah it was like telling
me like war stories and that got my
heart like what kind of stories was he
telling I can't remember it was just
like he was in the war and he killed
people he's telling you all he's doing
all you're selling your heart the same
guy when he was looking at it showed
like your blood like going in your heart
like red and coming out of your heart
blue like on the screen it was really
[ __ ] cool and and I just had like
this strong heart you know he said man
what a squeeze you know I like you know
what a squeeze did that in Austin Texas
- oh yeah yeah that was in Austin Texas
at this place called pharmaco AUTOSAR
right ii told you I got in the van with
that guy we drove ads in Northern
California to Lake Tahoe to try and get
jobs washing dishes at [ __ ] Valley to
get free snowboard passes but it wasn't
snowing so then we went to [ __ ]
Colorado and I got a job like cleaning a
meet room at a supermarket and that
sucked so I've got one with this other
didn't drove to Austin Texas and slept
on a roof until we got into the medical
study and then we left with two grams
and we were stoked and then like I you
know wound up like getting a car and
following the Grateful Dead and selling
drugs and she's my gosh you know I was
homeless for like three years and and
like periodically I get my hands on
cameras and do really [ __ ] up [ __ ] but
you know I was getting video footage but
like ultimately like you know I just
[ __ ] it was really bombed it wasn't
it didn't like after three years I
couldn't take anymore and I reached out
to my sister and she letting me move in
with her in Albuquerque and I was like I
would eat all their food and I wouldn't
[ __ ] work and no money and if I did
have money I was loaded and I was loud
you know so when my sister found out
about Ringling Brothers and Barnum &
Bailey Clown College she's like dude
this could be the way to get my brother
the [ __ ] out of my house like so like
she told me about it like I can't home
and she's like how are you getting to
Denver by Monday and I I hitchhiked from
Albuquerque to Denver and I got there in
two rides and just [ __ ] mine apeshit
have you written a book uh-huh okay is
this all in the book totally dude my
book at my books like it barely made the
New York Times bestseller list but
that's because you didn't come on here
first
probably yeah yeah I can't if people had
heard these [ __ ] stories and knew
that they were in the book oh my god it
barely made the best New York Times
bestseller list but what I'm most proud
of my book is my masterpiece man like on
Amazon it's got like the the key middle
of average rating is a full five out of
five stars
[ __ ] partial stars even people who
hate me and want to hate my book give it
a [ __ ] fire did you write it yourself
I worked for the writer on it but I
don't think anybody has like been more
involved in the collaboration like
that's all so we bounce
we've got Sal that [ __ ] back and forth
and like to it I wouldn't never use that
word I'm you know like my guy I worked
my dick off on that your story's [ __ ]
insane it's like it just has layers upon
layers of Tears
and that's kind of like what's dope
about the [ __ ] like the the comedy
show man I'm just like really bummed
like to retire like my [ __ ] you know how
are you retiring it what do you mean
well you know like you retire material
once the [ __ ] special company yeah we
make new stuff of course yeah please
it's a good opportunity for growth right
you want to be a comedy factory not a
comedy warehouse that's one way to look
at it
well your comedy should kind of
represent who you are right now oh yeah
20 years ago it doesn't really represent
who you're I don't [ __ ] like I told
you it's like the history is like super
condensed you know like you know so
that's like funny and with the story
points I'd like on story points I have
like when I say like about how I
graduated from Ringling Brothers and
Barnum & Bailey Clown College but like I
wasn't one of the clowns who got [ __ ]
contract with the circus so I had to
like borrow money to get a [ __ ]
Greyhound bus back to Albuquerque New
Mexico where I hung my fancy clown
costume in the [ __ ] closet and sold
shitty weed and the bags of [ __ ] weed
I saw did not weigh anywhere near what
they were supposed to weigh but in my
life [ __ ] sucked really bad but after
I got done ripping you off like at least
I would show you like a [ __ ] epic
unbelievable cool trick like this one
and then like on that point like well
[ __ ] bring like the table out and I'm
gonna [ __ ] show you the most
incredible bar trick ever so when did
you when did you put this book out at
2011 and did you go on the full tour do
all these radio shows and I mean I did
like radio tour like we'll see that must
have helped right yeah I didn't do like
terrible like um you need like a
platform where you could just talk for
hours and hours and hours right be cool
if I had like a podcast here I just
think that's what I'm saying
right everybody's tired of amigo and
dude you should have a podcast t-shirt
that says dude you should have a podcast
because I've seen so many people but
people took you up on it not every
podcast is the Joe Rogan experience you
know like it's the most [ __ ] annoying
question ever like hey will you do my
podcast yeah they did not it's it's one
of those things we got to kind of work
at it it doesn't seem like you have to
work on it like standard stand-up sort
of the same way of course we're doing
kill Tony last night that's one of the
things I wanted to tell people like it
seems like it's just you talking but you
figure out how people are perceiving you
and and that's that's a big part of
doing a podcast too but you would be
really good at it you really what I
think she just did like one a week
you'd probably it would take you a year
or two to run out of stories like who
knows it's like we're gonna tell us
stories about should that happen or
what's going on yeah dude do you have
like a guy that you could do it with we
could bounce [ __ ] off them you have a
good buddy that you've thought about
like five well with I've thought about
doing it you know there's this [ __ ]
platform this this um what you might
call it it's called you now one of these
streaming things like periscope or
meerkat but like but [ __ ] this is so
crazy like you now and like everybody
who is a user of this platform like a
like it has an account that they like
put money into and so the way it works
is like while you're streaming like you
like their questions show up and think
they want you to answer their questions
so they'll like they have like different
denominations of like money but they
like give you like a cam girl now agents
like bullied means doing it I tried it
right and I just sat there like just
telling stories to like the fans that
were [ __ ] watching and my by the end
of I was on there for like 39 minutes
and then I [ __ ] ended the stream and
it's like you just made $1,000 I feel
like a [ __ ] panhandler that is very
cam girl asked yeah but if you did that
all the time it would probably at least
pay for a studio if you set up a studio
so I mean for sure but you don't want
see you don't want two people to have to
pay to ask you questions I did this show
and the guy who promoted the show I
didn't know about it something to Bryan
Callen set up this guy love that guy
but these this guy had set it up and
brought I love Bryan to but he doesn't
pay attention to [ __ ] it's not like real
good with details I had to ask him a
bunch of questions about the show like
hey man is it
I was a DJ who's saying that he's
spinnin records in between us a week is
there a [ __ ] break in between us was
a DJ come on I'll check I'll check it's
just you and I I get there it's not just
me and him it's me Hamed is a [ __ ] MC
three local comics a girl's doing 20
minutes and it was a disaster we had to
clean up this giant mess his podcast no
no no it's a comedy show but the guy had
made people pay extra to take pictures
to meet us inside exactly and I said do
you can't do that never I would never do
that and you can't do that you can't do
that it's fun I take pictures with
everybody I'll do a theater now wait
four hours and I'll shake pictures with
a thousand [ __ ] people you can't
charge people an extra 20 bucks take
pictures of me
he did it on his own as a promoter and
this is all [ __ ] that kaolin just didn't
pay attention to the way the way I do
that I'm Brian's cool about taking
pictures oh yeah I know he is totally
cool he just didn't pay attention he
just let this guy handle everything
whoo we didn't need in the first place
you know what do you need use you know
we don't need a promoter this is Twitter
that's the promoter you know let people
know you're there they show up it's not
that hard like what does this promoter
in quotes doing what is he doing he's
just trying to get his friends on the
show and trying to charge extra to take
pictures it was stupid but right but
that's a gross model like the model of
like people having one day for VIP you
know all that gross [ __ ] agreed the one
thing though is the cell phone pictures
like take [ __ ] forever yes so what I
do is I have my my website no one
I'd take the pictures myself and like
when the [ __ ] I'm so good at it I
stole your idea we saw that Jamie comes
with me to some shows and takes pictures
and we better it's better just way
quicker third the time it's better to if
you take them yourself because that way
when the flash goes off you turn the
camera around he can show the people
their pictures so they can see it for
like quiet quality control don't let
them sit oh yeah cuz then they go oh my
god take that again oh my god girls who
like looking at photos of themselves and
everything's great look oh my god I hate
that picture do it again yeah
no no no this is what you look like yeah
but that's the thing is that like for me
like I'm my camera so fast boom I know
you don't like it how does I'm I don't
like it so I'll take another one
whatever dude my teeth look so [ __ ]
like and I just want the people to be
really like HAP I'm getting like a bunch
of cheese right man like I want them to
be super happy with it because I know
that when they [ __ ] go to my website
and pull it they're gonna post it on
their [ __ ] all their social media and
then that's that's sort of my grassroots
way of letting people know what the [ __ ]
I'm doing
yeah no it's smart move and I started
doing it right after I heard you did I
think Brian told me about it yeah and a
bunch of people do that now it's a girl
does that too right doesn't Gabriel go
something like that somewhere that's a
smart move
ok now like before I do my last [ __ ]
amazing stunt I'm gonna do every time I
want to thank you guys for coming out
and giving me a shot at stand-up and you
know I'm gonna [ __ ] when I walk off
the stage I'm not going anywhere
I'm so I take a photo with every single
one of you guys and here's how you get
amigo to my [ __ ] website and I explain
it real easy and I say and one last
thing if you want to get out of here a
little quicker the good news is I'm a
New York Times bestselling author and
I've got my [ __ ] my book and I've got
my [ __ ] like my hats my shirts and if
you guys want to get any of this [ __ ]
then that puts you to the front of the
line so having a March line and then a
photo oh there's so many merch line
first to get to the photo line through
the gift shop and it's like just [ __ ]
Disneyland take a picture the people by
March first you know and so like a lot
of people would would be like oh [ __ ]
man like I don't wanna you know I know I
Stella Mac if you don't want to get
anything that's great but please just
let me hang out like have a drink
whatever like but and just [ __ ] stick
around and get that picture so I can
thank you in person and a lot of people
will think like man like you know I want
to get a picture you know it wasn't to
buy anything but like [ __ ] I'll just buy
something to get the [ __ ] out here so
you end up selling like way more
work you know and nobody feels like
you're a dick you know you still stick
around and take a photo with everything
everyone and their [ __ ] the only
problem with selling things is you gotta
deal with people like $20 dude like
those people like oh just right how many
don't buy Doughboy how many people are
out there by selling [ __ ] a one
[ __ ] side one color [ __ ] shirt for
35 40 bucks like Andrew Dice Clay so it
sounds like a [ __ ] one color screen
drinks five shirts yeah he actually
brings like five shirts and the auctions
them off oh sure it's like 500 dollars
and that's not kidding yeah 20 bucks for
whatever but I sign every last [ __ ]
the sighs say it like hey you know you
can have a five-star New York Times
bestseller that's autographed by the
author in a picture and 20 bucks I don't
feel bad about no looked it's great for
a book you know book for 20 bucks is a
great deal you think about the amount of
time it's cost you know a book amount of
time that you spend being entertained by
that book books you're like the greatest
bargain ever yeah take days to read you
know yeah man that you have like as much
as you do man because I really we gotta
[ __ ] get this Paramount Theatre in
Austin but compact man I'm like that Joe
is gonna be like that's my Showtime well
you're gonna leave here and your phone's
gonna be buzzing off the hook with your
manager going did you say you're gonna
light the Paramount on fire
a huge stage and like dude he told me he
wanted to get out of the room don't
worry the right white there was like 23
people that just died recently a fire on
stage it just happened again where two
people in the band even died where was
it Sweden or something happened it's
parked on the side stage and immediately
the whole place pyrotechnics dude it's
not worth it we used to have those in
the UFC we stand these [ __ ] giant
like opening shows actually I don't
think we had yeah we did have fire
believe but in the joel de Oliveros like
this famous fighter from brazil and he
was fighting in Pride and they
accidentally lit him on fire and he was
on his way to the to the ring and you
know they do the boom when you're
walking through like this gateway they
like the fight and they they [ __ ] up
the timing they lit this [ __ ] dude on
fire as he's on his way into the ring
and burnt him and then they said the huh
you'll be back we give you a money and
so you know it took like a year off
healed up his [ __ ] 18 degree burns
and came back a year later and fought
again if you have anything like when you
go to the doctor do you have anything
that that bothers you still to this day
from like a stunt I know that's my
choice I have you know I'm in tours like
the big teeth and shitty tattoos most of
it but like my esophagus is [ __ ]
I got Barrett's esophagus it's like you
know like one of the warning signs for
esophageal cancer I'm just like like
acid reflux and I don't know drugs and
shitty living and vomiting do you take
care of yourself now you know cigarettes
I haven't smoked and you're a vegetarian
now right you haven't smoked in seven
years
Wow so right when you start getting
sober this yeah well I was five months
sober when I gave up cigarettes
I haven't smoked weed and since March
9th of 2008 so no coffee and thanks for
not smoking weed for this one
oh no I appreciate it no worries I
wouldn't want to get you secondhand
Lambay I said but although some people
keep telling me that's [ __ ] but I
know it's not a pot I just I don't
really give a [ __ ] of people drink
around me but like the weeks I'm like
breathing and like it's like the problem
is it [ __ ] it smells great it smells
great in it I do believe secondhand
smoke gets you high I don't think it
gets you as high smoking pot but I think
secondhand smoke still affects you so
vegan there's a whole other [ __ ] like
major other door which other door like
and this this I'm gonna [ __ ] let
people see this something at in Austin
or at the show time but it's like you
know it's like I'm good rehab it and
like it's serving the whole deal and
then it's like alright well it's great
that I've learned how to live without
[ __ ] drugs and alcohol but like now
I'm going to address my sex addiction I
got was my deal I was like you know it's
a mean joke I tell but you know I said
I'm like I'm [ __ ] 41 now I'm looking
like my future and you know like I don't
want to be 51 and falling apart and
trying to hump everything that moves I
don't want to turn into Pauly Shore I'm
sure there's a few other guys just
[ __ ] ride that boat right into the
rock I'll go with Lemmy before I would
go with Vince Motorhead's like right
right I just honestly believe you're
married right it's like I really
leave that like to be like happy you
know like it's it's important to have
[ __ ] I have a life partner and not run
around tryin to [ __ ] everybody and
screwing them over you know I'm like
that's the deal like I like how can I
give so much of a [ __ ] about animals
that I won't [ __ ] eat an animal but I
have no respect for women at all you
know like it doesn't add up like so like
on my [ __ ] path and once I got into
the the meditation like I've been doing
Transcendental Meditation for two and a
half years now and like I couldn't you
know once I got into that like it was
just like glaring like a [ __ ]
flashing red light like stop [ __ ]
screwing over chicks you know and and
[ __ ] using them up and throwing them
away and just like you know like and
whatever if I'm on the road like [ __ ]
hooking up with all the chicks it's just
like it just became clear like that's
pretty much like a path to being [ __ ]
miserable and it's a type of addiction
yeah for sure like it's like anything
outside like you know I've made myself
like a promise I'm like okay now I'm
like I want to [ __ ] learn how to be
in a healthy relationship because I feel
like that time I'm gonna be happy and so
I'm gonna [ __ ] them from here on out I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna [ __ ] random
chicks on that I'm gonna stop trying to
get my dick sucked everywhere you know
got the [ __ ] stage I'm not gonna go
anywhere I take a picture with everybody
so the whole [ __ ] audience basically
gets in a line and it's an audition to
see who gets to suck my dick [ __ ] the
whole thing I mean I remember like that
guy gets his dick sucked no [ __ ] he's
in the [ __ ] way there's a sex program
you need somebody to oversee both of you
guys
I'm stoked I'm an because now I'm like
[ __ ] yeah I'm like I got in therapy
like the whole deal and which is
hilarious because like you know my whole
story arc you know is like it's it's
pretty epic you know to go from where I
was at to where I'm at now you know at
the end I think at the end of the show
I'm gonna have to [ __ ] break out my
old lightbulb trick and so I can slash
my [ __ ] and bleed everywhere just just
because like to [ __ ] to try to
[ __ ] like about the end of my [ __ ]
show it's like okay so now I'm like a
[ __ ] vegan and you know like trying
not to get my dick like clean and sober
like [ __ ] a healthy eater you know
meditating like the least I can do is
[ __ ] bleed all over myself out sure
you're a vegan because you love animals
that's how I got into it okay
but you feed your animals animals I do
feed my dogs dog food that has fish in
it and I just I just adopted a cat and
the same thing right right it's terrible
I did it for what if they don't it's not
they have to be like like at the point
of hunger we're like you're willing to
eat your own [ __ ] foot that kind of
[ __ ] up you know it's like you're
choosing the animals that you love
you're feeding these animals other
animals that were captive in my movie
if you want to be like super black and
white like PETA PETA I mean that's the
reality of animals right I mean I just I
don't know I mean I hear that like the
even in my [ __ ] canvas you know
slip-on vans that there's some kind of
animal products and then in the rubber
right yeah a lot of like I'm not gonna
not get photographed because there's
animal products in the film you know
like I just do the best I can and I feel
better I feel better for doing it ya
know it's is this the animal thing is
weird when people are super
self-righteous about killing animals and
yet they have pets I've had a real issue
with that with people I guess
one spot that's why I like I'm like
really [ __ ] committed to not trying
to tell other people what to do you know
have your whopper man I'm here like eat
all meat you want I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm just happier myself like you know
trying to why vegan what about like
farm-fresh eggs or things along those
lines when I was with with fish and eggs
like wow they went back to being fully
vegan mm-hmm but you know because I'm
[ __ ] feel tired all the time I'm like
man what is it I think it's my diet and
I think it might fish and eggs then all
of a sudden I'll have more energy but
does it happen
no I [ __ ] had a sleep study it turns
out I got sleep apnea is a CPAP machine
no I use a mouthpiece
I'll turn you on to a doctor that's
please local that makes a really good
one a lot of people that have it it's
your tongue for I have a fat tongue yeah
yeah and this physician like to get
cleared for a TV show and she was trying
the light in the back of my throat she
said do you feel like you sleep a whole
night and wake up and you're still tired
I'm like yes she says well then the back
year through its really narrow and I
think that's gonna cause it sleep back
yeah the holes narrow yeah I have that
too
and also like I talked to me about
getting an operation when they take out
your adenoids and your tonsils and it's
pretty intense and it's it's it sucks
for like a week but then after it's over
you have a larger hole and I have larger
holes better for sleeping but this
serves me well do you still get up to
piss as much oh yeah if I have to piss
if I try not to drink before I go to bed
like right Friday but if I do yeah I got
a [ __ ] big [ __ ] water pitcher next
I bet on the floor so I just picked up a
piss and put it back my friend Matt
Serra who is a former UFC welterweight
champion when I first met him he had
this gym in Long Island and he used to
sleep in the basement of his gym he's
just teach and then go downstairs and
sleep and
here this jug right next to bed cuz
finders will drink like gallons and
water that day they just drink water all
the time to flush our system out and he
would just whip his dick out he goes I
didn't even get out of bed I would turn
sideways put my dick in the hole piss
pull it out put the jug down right back
this I did so great man this one black
water pitcher like I don't have a very
big dick or anything but like I don't
even really have to tip over man because
I gets got like about things where those
classic kool-aid good to go
so when you got a sleep study they put
all the electrodes on your chest
how many times did you wake up in an
hour they said that it was actually like
mild to moderate mm-hmm but but still I
mean I know I gotta get that [ __ ]
mouth yeah it's not well you should lose
weight I need an engine wait is the big
one I think that's like what Joey Diaz
Joey Diaz uses the CPAP machine but he
didn't used to have to have that it's
like when he got really big that's when
he really developed because the more fat
you have its salt closes everything off
you know right when you see people with
giant jowls well guess what that fats
everywhere it's inside your face it's
inside your neck and all that fat will
close off the hole and when you lay back
and your tongue falls over that hole
there's no errands right I had to wake a
guy up man I was on a plane this [ __ ]
guy was not breathing for like minutes
at a time and then then gagging and
coughing and then I'm wake him up but I
talk to him when he woke up and I said
hey man have you ever gotten checked for
sleep apnea because he was it was
snoring the most ungodly snoring so
funny [ __ ] wake up I'm gonna get
sued like you're not worried about the
kids who's got spiked on his head I
tried this poor guy was freaking me out
because he was making these noises and
then he would go back to like
and then it would be nothing no sound
and I'm awake because I was writing and
it was on the long flight and I looked
over at this guy and I'm noticing he's
very overweight and it's just lying
there like this no movement no breathing
no no movement at all in his chest and
all son like I mean he would go I mean
I'm exaggerating over saying minutes but
he would definitely go 40 seconds like I
time did I forget what the time was but
I remember being alarmed and I remember
sitting up going okay I got to talk to
this guy and I had my mouthpiece with me
because I bring it in my dad moves your
lower jaw forward no no no no mine
doesn't mine actually just depresses my
tongue down and it keeps my tongue from
falling back over my ear hole it depends
on what kind of sleep apnea hmm I don't
know what's the difference I don't know
Joey would know more than anyone because
Joey's got it real bad Joey needs the
CPAP like he has to have air blow in it
I love them too it's probably smoking
weed right now I'm paranoid but anyway
so I the guy was like kind of stirring
and moving and when he finally was like
opening his eyes and looking around I
talked to him and I had like a long
sit-down with him I showed him the
mouthpiece I'm gonna go dude you could
die I go you you hold your I was gonna
film it but I thought it would be rude
just film you but I mean you're holding
your breath for a long time if you ever
talk to anyone about it it's like no you
know my wife tells me I snore I go dude
you don't just snore you're like choking
you know and there's a lot of people you
don't know what happens when you go to
sleep you're out and you sleep you're
out and when you're out like that you're
not getting any oxygen when you sleep
you don't get into heavy REM sleep
you're gonna get into those deep cycles
you just skirt the edges and then you
wake up cuz your body's gasping in panic
mode and so you'll wake up after like
eight hours of sleep and still [ __ ]
exhausted every day I feel like I could
go back to bed right when I wake up you
really could lose weight I mean you know
that's a big social Joey Joey I mean
that's a big thing with Joey's way way
way overweight and he got down a while
just like you did I mean Joey lost like
80 [ __ ] pounds at one point but he's
he gets the energy from that CPAP like
he feels way bed
like he travels with one he has this
machine that he travels with that he has
to check I mean so he always has to
check his luggage because his carry-on
is his CPAP machine so he doesn't go
anywhere without checking his luggage
every flight he takes Joey brings that
machine with him that is his [ __ ]
that's his security system you brought
up earlier you brought up Greg
Fitzsimmons I don't Cosby thing what do
you think about because I it makes me
feel out weird I don't like it it's
misguided I love Greg but I think it's
misguided and for folks who don't know
what we're talking about Greg has
decided to start stealing Bill Cosby's
material and doing it openly so he does
these classic Bill Cosby bits and then
he lets everybody know in the middle of
it that he's stealing Bill Cosby's bits
to take away from him what is most
precious but it doesn't really work
because it doesn't you don't like if
someone tries to steal some [ __ ] off of
like shiny happy jihad or something like
that like it's already out it's already
on CD I did it and you know [ __ ] 2006
like if you're stealing you're not
taking anything away from me
you're just you just you know you're
just selling yourself short by stealing
so like if Greg does Bill Cosby's
material you don't ever take it away
from him it's already recorded these are
like he doesn't even do that material
anymore so I don't know I don't think
it's really effective it seems like
you're taking something negative and
being negative about it it just doesn't
seem it and I also think it's just opens
the door to people go well Greg stole
Bill Cosby's jokes you know and but he
says it on stage they're stealing it he
lets people know in the middle of it
that he's stealing Bill Cosby's but Greg
Fitzsimmons steals Bill Cosby's bits now
he does he's doing it on purpose to try
to take something from Bill Cosby like
this is the idea behind it I think it
sounds like Bill Cosby would be super
psyched on that because it's like wow
I'm getting credit for being funny and
it's distracting people from Vegas
totally true that's completely defeating
yeah I think it's a gimmick I mean III
see what he's like he's genuinely thinks
the guy's disgusting right it's general
I mean I glorify his comedy but yeah I
mean I don't get it either
I don't know I just I don't know maybe
if I had him on and Greg oh hell monsoon
and he's gonna be on soon I guess we
were talking about doing something
within the next couple weeks so maybe
he'll explain it better I just I
wouldn't want to have anything to do
with it you know you know I'd say this
up fascinate there's some lady that was
on who was a legal expert who was
discussing it and she said he might be
the most prolific serial rapist in
history which is [ __ ] insane it's
insane to look at it that way that this
guy mr. Huxtable
you know the [ __ ] guy from the TV
show the guy who had the squeaky clean
comedy the guy who did the bit about you
know the football players saying hi mom
to his son on TV this guy was like
wholesome mr. America in a sweater but
they said none of these girls like the
next morning well god what the [ __ ]
happened he raped me I am going to to
the police this is all you know kind of
like wishy-washy like yeah I kind of
felt weird that night but no one really
went right to the police though did they
um I don't know I don't know it seems
weird it sounds like if it seemed weird
to me seems like a lot of people just
kind of I don't know well listen man if
you're a girl okay look at it this way
you're some young girl who's trying to
make it in show business and you're you
know you get brought into his office
because you know his you know he knows
your parents or something that that was
a lot of the situation like he there was
one of one situation was there was like
a modeling company and he would contact
the Milan company to get people on his
show like he was looking to cast but
roles that didn't even exist
yeah he would bring them into his office
and drugged them like would you like a
cappuccino and give them a cappuccino
and [ __ ] them I mean just drugged them I
don't know it seems saying if that were
to happen though like four hours
this girl's good I just went there for
an interview I had a cappuccino and he
[ __ ] me like you'd go right to the
zone this is why this is why no because
I think I was gonna say is like these
these are young girls that are probably
completely overwhelmed that they're even
in his presence like they can't even
believe that they're meeting Bill Cosby
so you're insanely starstruck and the
fact that he's touching you puts you
into a state of shock like you're [ __ ]
and then you're confused because you
wake up and you're you were drugged you
don't know what happened and then you're
embarrassed and horrified of it I mean
there's so many extremes mr. Huxtable
exactly it's like he's this is before
the internet man you know for girl like
that if that happened today a girl could
go on her Facebook page and say today I
went on an audition with Bill Cosby and
he drugged me and raped me and like whoa
like BAM that takes off and he goes
viral
but back then man if you go to the
[ __ ] police they might not say [ __ ]
or money they might go to Cosby and
Cosby might sue you but you got to
realize some women did and in 2005 he
actually paid off women and he that's
why this all got more serious lately is
because they released the transcripts
and the transcripts said that he
admitted that he had drugged these girls
he admitted it so this this did go to
cops and it didn't go out to the public
so it's like it's not kind of weird it's
just the amount of power and money this
got I mean Bill Cosby is like a
billionaire I mean the amount of money
that guy has is insane and the amount of
power that kind of money has were you
talking about just teams of lawyers that
just try to figure on any sort of attack
that they could do to try to mitigate
any of the issues that are going on with
people accusing him of all this crazy
you know rape [ __ ] it's like he fought
it for a long time he hasn't really
publicly denied any of it no he hasn't
denied it at all
he hasn't denied it all he just doesn't
talk about it you know he one of the
weirdest things that he said he did this
one interview and he said in all my
years of show business I've never seen
anything
this yeah well that's called free speech
this is what's going on now look you you
everyone can talk now like now people
can get online and talk about crimes
that you committed it's you can't hide
behind lawyers anymore you can't
threaten them you know you can't you you
and you're a girl you're barely paying
your bills you know you're barely
getting by and he offers you twenty
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars just shut the [ __ ] up and you
have to sign some written agreement that
says you never speak about this again
you take that money that's what they do
and that's what they did in 2005 and I
don't know how much they got paid but
it's probably even more than that
probably a million I mean when you when
you're worth what that guy's made in his
career I'm who knows what he's got left
but but someone a hundred thousand here
or a hundred thousand there for a guy
like that there's nothing he could
silence a lot of [ __ ] but just keeping
people quiet with money you know and
that's probably what happened when
things came up me I don't know and then
there's also people feet with fear of
being blackballed you know being
blackballed from show business when
you're a struggling actress and you're
barely getting by the difference between
Bill Cosby talking badly about you and
accusing you of being a liar like who's
gonna listen to you and who's gonna
listen to him
they gotta think that most people gonna
listen to Bill Cosby and that could
wreck your career before it ever gets
started just sink your ship and it seems
like a lot of these girls that he preyed
on were trying to make it in show
business that was a big part of like
what he would attack he would go after
these girls that were trying to become
actresses and he was like a mentor
figure that was like the angle that he
was presenting stark [ __ ] man get on
that I take one piss Simmons and his
Bill Cosby strategy yeah it's a little
misguided I think I don't know I mean
maybe Greg's got a better point maybe we
need to let him articulate it it's the
darkest thing in all of the history of
stand-up comedy I think I mean or close
to it you know I mean what else there
was that Vince champ guy that was raping
college girls and he got caught he would
say like horrible [ __ ]
to them like pray for me and stuff like
while he's [ __ ] them that guy's in
jail for the rest of his life Cosby is
just out running around I mean it
doesn't seem like there's any charges
that are being put up against him and as
far as I know there's only one woman
that the the rape happened inside the
statute of limitations I don't know what
the statute of limitations is but I
think it's like that's it
that seems [ __ ] I think a rape I think
it's seven years but that's kind of like
whoa you know it's a little wishy-washy
meaning like if you if you rape somebody
and you have great proof eight years
later I'm sure there's still gonna I
don't know I don't think that's the case
I think a statute of limitations is
pretty rock-solid like once it yeah yeah
it's not it's it's law you know I don't
know it's [ __ ] up we've talked about
that so many times it's so it's a
subject that's been beaten to death but
if it seems like it's so significant
that you kind of have to beat it to
death
cuz it's hard to believe magic that was
like your dad or something like that
imagine you know if you found out your
dad was a [ __ ] serial rapist or your
mom even your mom's drug and dude that
sucking their dicks I saw you do about
if your son came home from school and
told told you that his teachers dick
knows that he called the cops my son
called the police cause uh how does
someone ever find out that a female
teacher molested kid one of those
[ __ ] has to open his mouth okay
there's a giant difference she no woman
molesting a boy and a man molesting a
girl I don't think it should be
encouraged but it's certainly not the
same right did you hear about anonymous
releasing all the KKK members
information supposedly there's a lot of
US senators I applaud you anonymous
I feel like an anonymous overall across
the board does more good [ __ ] okay I
know I hear very very
you bad accusations on their part almost
everything they do I agree with I love
it like it good [ __ ] the KKK [ __ ] all
those crazy [ __ ] Stone Age [ __ ]
who give a [ __ ] about the origin of
birth of your great-great-great
grandparents you know you're not pule
you're not of the pure race it's gonna
be interesting though because supposedly
there's some ferguson police that are
involved in this and it the whole list
officially gets released and i think
next week or this you want Browns on it
well they can just put your name on it
man somebody wanted to [ __ ] with you
steve-o's in the KKK what yeah you
you've you've kind of morphed it's
really fascinating I mean seeing you go
from being this wild crazy ketamine
snortin psychopath jumping off roofs and
[ __ ] and damaging buddy to being this
vegan who's trying to live a kind life
and trying to be nice to people and you
don't want to randomly hook up with
girls cuz you want to have a meaningful
relationship and then taking care of
animals and [ __ ] SeaWorld it's really
amazing to see these become this every
once in a while I gotta do something
pretty [ __ ] up just to make sure that
well I didn't meet you until you were
sober right you know I missed the crazy
train I've kept it pretty crazy sober to
them ya know no doubt yeah I mean just
explaining what you're planning on doing
it to Paramount before they found out
about it do you think there's gonna be a
jack house jackass for K or something
like that I don't think so man but old
and [ __ ] injury last one was so great
how I can I'm working my dick off to get
my own movie oh yeah yeah like sort of
sort of like the bad grandpa format but
so my thought was bad grandpa good oh
yeah that was a funny funny funny I
cried when he got his dick stuck in that
machine oh my god it was one of the
funny that was a funny [ __ ] movie
that I was really good
I don't think got enough
read it I really don't think you got as
much credit as it deserved
I think it did well it was number one
but it's one of the funniest movies I've
ever seen in my life and when you talk
about like funny all-time movies very
few people bring up bad grandpa I think
they should I think it's a goddamn epic
movie there's some kids [ __ ] on the
wall and when he's dancing
that kids awesome I love the kid in it
when he goes to the black Club and he's
with all the ladies and he's dancing
come on okay it's [ __ ] epic movie
yeah
should you have a movie worked out or do
you have a night tell you much yeah I'm
gonna like keep the cards close to chest
yeah dude but but I got a deal with the
yeah big-time movie producer guys oh
snap yes now weird and I got and taking
it and like getting it written and get
the director and then take it to the
studios kind of deal so we were talking
about this this damage it's done really
the [ __ ] on back we're talking about the
damage you've done to your body before
you went off to pee and you said
esophagus other than that like pretty
margins and joints and back that joints
are all good that's crazy
what about Knoxville is he okay he's
gotten some back issues I think so from
that bowl I wish when he went blindfold
the bull particularly her Don I think
that one thing one thing that did a lot
of damage to him was early early on
dropping in on the skateboard halfpipe I
think I'm one of the big vert ramps
mm-hmm
and he just like I mean just fell
straight to the flat bottom and like I
remember like hearing that like you know
he turns his like turning the car like
hurts his shoulders [ __ ] he definitely
did more damage because like he didn't
have like the benefit of growing up like
falling off a skateboard sort of
learning how to fall down you know like
when he'd like a lot of us are like sort
of you know I mean I'm like you know
sort of circus clown
combate you know lifelong [ __ ] by trades
yeah
so yes I'm kind of more like like I'm
better at falling down without getting
hurt knocks it falls down I just meet
hitting the ground in the worst way
which is why his shits always the best
you know oh oh yeah that makes sense
because you can do flips and all that
[ __ ] you know how to fall with your body
yeah more like a cat when it's down do
it and Knoxville is just you know I
think that he's probably in worse shape
but then again at the same time I think
that uh you know he takes good care of
him sobbing you know and I think maybe
he's done some bending I get some disk
issues I don't know mmm yeah I've got a
gang of those I did my own stunts for
this accidentally did my own stunts for
this Kevin James movie I wasn't excited
I suck at riding bikes I had to ride a
bike and I had hit him with a flag which
Kevin James is zookeeper and I was the
guy that I'm telling me about is when I
did that movie which guy Todd garner oh
the guy who the producer I know Todd
yeah dude
so I had to hit the brake while I was
like riding a bike and I was hitting him
with this flag but I'm hitting the front
brake and when you you know you hit the
front brake if it locks you go flying
over the top and I did it like three
times ask if we wind up using that in
the movie instead of the stunt man
because I just want to go [ __ ] fly
but I'm pretty good at falling there's a
life-long you know martial artist so
although like that I knew when I hit the
ground that you can't just hit the
ground you gotta kind of like roll with
but you really have a real strong
appreciation for stunt people when you
do something like that because I go well
I got through this
luckily without getting hurt but if I
had to do this every [ __ ] day or you
know every week some new thing where
you've fallen off of a building or
jumping off of a [ __ ] moving car that
potential for damaging yourself is super
high now you hear about those people
dying it's always like some movie that
no one's gonna give a [ __ ] about some
racing motorcycle seen a Steven Seagal
movie and someone dies you know I mean
you got a when you watch those crazy
action movies think about that
appreciate the fact that those people
they
literally put their physical health and
their life on the line for your
entertainment you know I didn't think
about it too much until I just [ __ ] up
and fell a few times on a bike in a
movie you know it's like those guys do
it on purpose all the time yeah that's
right ma'am it's [ __ ] hard gig man
that's a harder said the [ __ ]
paramount all right ladies and gentlemen
let's wrap this [ __ ] up steve-o steve-o
on Twitter Paramount Theater November
21st Austin Texas I will be in Denver at
that time I'm at the Belko Theatre on
November 21st with the great Ian Edwards
and then the 20th I'm in Madison
Wisconsin on the 20th all that [ __ ] is
on my website Joe Rogan net in the tour
section Brian we got going on Wednesday
we're at the Comi stormy in you oh
that's right mr. Leo a secret show and
also means our secret secret guests yeah
some secret guess I've never really
groans with Bosh hopefully in awesome
Antonia bringing kill Tony to Pittsburgh
in Ohio Thanksgiving week it's November
27th we'll be in Pittsburgh in November
29th in Ohio good to desk wha TV click
on tour yee-ha all right you [ __ ]
I got a podcast in one hour with Chris
Ryan so I'll see you then bye-bye big
kiss thanks Joe
[Music]